THIS MEETING TO ORDER ON
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
ARE FIRST INFORMATIONAL HEARING
TODAY WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH- I HAVE A QUITE A LONG
LIST OF HOUSEKEEPING SO I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND START ON
THAT- WE ARE OF COURSE CONTINUE
TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SEEN HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL SO WE
WILL ONLY BE ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO
WATCH THIS HEARING IN PERSON
WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASS
B. WARREN WARREN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED. BY ALL
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM- AND IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES.
FOR TESTIMONY TODAY PUBLIC
TESTIMONY OPTIONS INCLUDE
TESTIFYING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM ON THE PHONE OR VIA THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION ON THE
NORTH SIDE OF THE CAPITOL. AS A
REMINDER I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY OF THE
pINDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISTRICT ROB
DEV MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE
CHAMBER OR REMOTE MEDIAN
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY DURING THE
PUBLIC. COMMENTPERIOD I WILL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I'D ALSO ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TO TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. UP
FOR OUR DIAL IN WITNESSES WE
WILL. ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THERE WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMUNICATIONS INCOME VANCE
WEBSITE OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AND ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU
ARE CALLING THEN YOU WOULD BE
PLACE IN THE QUEUE UNTIL IT IS
TIME FOR YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY WE
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE ACT.
916-319-2630 SEVEN. AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTER ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. MY FINAL POINT ASSEMBLY
HAS EXPERIENCE A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE
EMPLOYER PROCEEDINGS AND THE
LAST FEW YEARS. CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASK IN REFUSING TO PUT IT BACK
ON. TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE.
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE AND OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACCESS TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT I WOULD TAKE
THE FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WARNED THEM THAT
CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY RESULT
IN REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. I WILL ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED AT THE NATURE OF THE
JUST AND THE NATURE OF THE
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT. I MAY ALSO
TEMPORARILY RECEIPT RECESSED THE
HEARING IF THE CONDUCT DOES NOT
STEP I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
ESCORTING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COP COOPERATION. AND I
KNOW WE WON'T HAVE ANY OF THOSE
INSTANCES HERE BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO BE A VERY FRIENDLY
COMMAND COMMITTEE- WELL FIRST
THIS IS EXCITING TO SHARE MY
FIRST COMMUNICATION AND
CONVENIENCE COMMITTEES HEARING
AND- I'M NOT ONLY EXCITED BUT-
HAPPY TO SEE MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE- WE'VE INVITED
SEVERAL. MEMBERS OF THE SPEAKERS
BROADBAND WORKING GROUP TO
PARTICIPATE GIVEN THEIR REGULAR
INVOLVEMENT ON THIS TOPIC. AS
SOME OF YOU MAY OR MAY NOT NOTE
THIS BROADBAND WORKING GROUP HAS
BEEN MEETING FOR WELL OVER A
YEAR. ON THAT NOTE I'D LKE TO
GET IN THANK SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON FOR APPOINTMENT
APPOINTING ME TO LEAD THIS
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE. ESPECIALLY
AT THE TIME WHEN THE ISSUES ARE
FOCUSED. ON OUR SO TIMELY. THERE
CONTINUES TO BE A GREAT FOCUS ON
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
ENSURING DIGITAL EQUITY BOTH
FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND THE NEW
CEMENT MINISTRATION. I'D LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES ON THIS
COMMITTEE. AND THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS OVERALL FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT ON THESE
ISSUES. AND MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES. FORTUNATELY THERE'S
ALSO A LOT OF SUPPORT FROM
CONGRESS AND THE VITAMINS
ADMINISTRATIONS SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA HAS RECEIVED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN FEDERAL SUPPORT TO
HELP OUR STATE RECOVER AND BUILD
BACK BETTER FROM THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THE VIRUS BECOMES AN ENDEMIC WE
MUST REMAIN COMMITTED TO SOLVING
THE ISSUES. THAT AFFECT OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIA
THOUSANDS OF HOUSEHOLDS IN. ALL
PARTS OF OUR STATE RURAL AND
URBAN STILL LACK ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE RELIABLE HIGH SPEED
INTERNET CONNECTION. AND I WANT
TO UNDERSCORE THAT BECAUSE SOME
OF US MAY FEEL THAT THERE ARE
SOME AREAS THAT ARE BETTER
CONNECTED THAN OTHERS AND THAT
IS TRUE BUT WE STILL FIND.
NEIGHBORHOODS AND AREAS WHERE
THERE IS NO CONNECTION AND YEAH
EVEN IN A VERY CONNECTED AREA-
THIS IS WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY AS
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE NEW SAMYN MINISTRATION MADE
A HISTORIC SIX BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM. THROUGH
SENATE BILL ONE FIVE SIX A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE MONEY
WAS FEDERAL FOREIGN FUNDING WITH
STRICT TIMELINES AND GUIDELINES
AND HOW IT IS SPENT AS THE
MINISTRATION MOVES AHEAD TO
IMPLEMENT ALL PROGRAMS FUNDED IN
THAT LEGISLATION I AM COMMITTED
TO HAVING THIS COMMITTEE PLAY. A
STRONG OVERSIGHT ROLE
UNDERSCORING OVERSIGHT ROLE
TODAY'S HEARING WILL FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON THE MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND INITIATIVE IN THE
FUTURE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS THAT
WE HAVE PLAN WILL FOCUS ON THE
LAST MILE PROGRAM SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND. BECAUSE THE TWO APPROACHES
WE NEED BOTH OF THOSE TOGETHER
TO SOLVE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
THEY MUST GO HAND IN HAND. WE
CANNOT HAVE A EFFECTIVE LAST
MILE SOLUTIONS FOR HOUSEHOLDS
THAT NEED IT UNLESS THERE IS A
OPERATIONAL MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
THE MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND
INITIATIVE IS THE STATE SOLUTION
TO THE PROBLEM. AND WITH THAT
I'M GONNA NOW OPEN IT UP FOR
REMARKS- FROM OUR VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE WITH YOU AND WELCOME.
MEMBERS I HAVE BEEN SERVING ON
THE UTILITY AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
AT ALSO HERE AT CMC. AND WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT CLOSING THIS
DIGITAL DIVIDE FOR AT LEAST NINE
OR TEN YEARS. WE HAVE LOTS OF
MONEY NOW IN THE PIPELINE. AND
SO I WANT US TO RECOGNIZE
SOMETHING THAT. THIS IS
ACHIEVABLE. WE CAN CLOSE THIS
GAP. IT IS A FINITE. OBLA WE
THINK THERE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
ON SERVED. THAT IS AN ACHIEVABLE
GOAL PARTICULARLY WITH THE
FUNDING WE HAVE. I THINK WE NEED
TO RECOGNIZE ALSO THAT THE
PROVIDERS ARE READY THEY'RE
WILLING THEY'RE ABLE THEY'RE AT
THE TABLE. AND THEY REALLY WANT
TO BE A PARTNER IN THIS AND YET
I THINK SOME GET CONCERNED THAT
THE BUREAUCRACIES THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THIS. ARE BASICALLY
MAYBE SAYING NO WAIT MAY BE
PUSHING IT OFF FOR A PERIOD O
TIME. I WANT TO RAISE THE
CONCERN THAT THE P. YOU SEE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
THEY NEED TO BE BUREAUCRACIES
THAT. SMOOTHED OUT THIS PROCESS
GET THE DETERMINATIONS DONE AND
GET THE THAT THE MONEY INTO THE
- IT INTO PLACES WHERE IT NEEDS
TO BE. AND WE NEED TO REMIND
OURSELVES S. B. ONE FIVE SIX WAS
VERY CLEAR SURE THE UNSERVED.
AND I THINK IF WE MISS THAT
OPPORTUNITY IF WE'RE BOGGED DOWN
IN SOME OF THIS BUREAUCRATIC
DECISION MAKING. AND OF THE P.
YOU SEE TAKES UPON ITSELF SOME.
OF THE DESIRE TO HEAD IN A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION THAN WHAT SB ONE FIVE
SIX WAS VERY CLEAR. WE MAY ENTER
INTO A TIME WHERE WE WASTE A LOT
OF MONEY. WE CAN'T DRAW DOWN ALL
THE FEDERAL MONEY OUT BECAUSE OF
IT AND I THINK WE GOT TO BE VERY
VERY CAREFUL. ABOUT HOW THESE
BUREAUCRACIES GET US TO THE
FINISH LINE. THEY NEED TO BE
STREAMLINED THEY NEED TO BE
EFFICIENT THEY NEED TO GET US TO
THE PLACE WHERE WE ACTUALLY HAVE
PEOPLE IN THOSE AREAS
CONSTRUCTING DOING IT- WITH THE
VERY LATEST TECHNOLOGY. I HOPE
THAT AT THE END OF ALL OF THIS.
AND I HOPE IT'S SOON. WE WILL
SEE THOSE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS. AND WE WILL
BE ABLE TO SAY. WE'VE DONE IT SO
LET'S DO IT AND LET'S NOT LET
BARACK CHRISSY'S GET IN THE WAY.
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO BE AN
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE I APPLAUD
THE CHAIR. FOR HER WILLINGNESS
TO TAKE ON THE OVERSIGHT ROLE OF
THIS THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WERE HERE. AND SO WILL COME
BACK. SEVERAL MORE TIMES. AND WE
WILL CHECK ON THE PROGRESS AND
I'M HOPING. THAT WE'VE MADE THE
PROGRESS CLEAR THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE. AND THAT WILL ACTUALLY SEE
THAT PROGRESS TAKE PLACE. THIS
IS A GOLDEN MOMENT AND
CALIFORNIA IS STANDING AT A
CROSSROADS. LET'S DO IT NOT NOT
NO NOT WAIT NOT MAYBE LET'S DO
IT. NOW GET IT DONE WE HAVE THE
MONEY WE HAVE THE WHERE WITH
ALL. MY CONCERN IS WHEN THEY RUN
OUT OF TIME. BECAUSE A LOT OF
THAT MONEY HAS TO BE SPENT. SO
LET'S RUN OUR SLEEVES UP. THOSE
THAT ARE INVOLVED BOTH FROM THE
PUBLIC SECTOR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. LET'S AGREE THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE TIME WE END THE
DIGITAL FIVE. THANK YOU AND I'M
GONNA OPEN IT UP TO ANY OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ANY
INTRODUCTION COMMENTS. SOMEONE
MEMBER RAYOS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I WANT TO SAY THAT I'M
VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE AND- I
APPLAUD THE SPEAKER FOR.
APPOINTING YOU TO THIS POSITION
YOU HAVE BEEN A STRONG
PROPONENT. OF INTERNET TROLL AND
TO MAKING SURE THAT EQUITY IS AT
THE TOP OF THE LIST WE LOOK AT
THE ISSUES THAT- AFFECT OUR
COMMUNITY. HAVING ACCESS TO
RELIABLE AFFORDABLE HIGH SPEED
INTERNET IS A NECESSITY IN
TODAY'S LIFE IT ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT WE THINK SOME PEOPLE
DESERVE AND OTHERS DON'T OR SOME
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE AND OTHERS
DON'T NEED IT. WE'VE SEEN IT
WITH THE STUDENTS YEAH DURING
COVERT THAT WAS THE ONLY WAY
THEY COULD GET THEIR LESSONS-
BUT WE'VE ALSO SEEN IT WOULD IN
MEDICINE THOSE ARE THE
APPOINTMENTS IT'S BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS YOUR- YOUR YOUR DOCTOR
WOULD DIFFER JOB APPLICATIONS.
FOR TELEWORK IT AND SO MANY
THINGS IT IS NOT A LUXURY IT IS
ABSOLUTELY. A REQUIREMENT FOR
MODERN LIFE. THE I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WE FINALLY GET
THE MONEY. NOW WE'VE GOT TO DO
THE HARD WORK AND HAVING THIS
OVERSIGHT- HEARING IS THAT IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FIRST STEP- I
APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT AYE AYE I
AM VERY PROUD AS YOU'VE SAID.
I'M VERY PROUD OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
INVESTING SUBSTANTIAL FUNDING
AND I THINK THAT THIS COULD DO
EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE SET OUT TO
DO AND THAT IS TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. THERE ARE THE
THREE THINGS THAT WE ALWAYS
ALWAYS LOOK AT IT THAT IS
ACCESSIBILITY. RELIABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY. IT ACCESSIBILITY
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE THE
MIDDLE MILE IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO.
ACCOMPLISH WE THEN HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVEN FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE ACCESSIBILITY. IF THE
INTERNET CONNECTION IS NOT
RELIABLE OR IF IT IS NOT
AFFORDABLE IT'S AS IF THEY HAD
NO INTERNET CONNECTION. AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT I KNOW THAT WE
WILL BE LOOKING OUT TO IN THE
FUTURE SO I LOOK FORWARD TO. TO
THIS OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE HEARING
AND I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
AS WELL TO ITS VERY. REAFFIRMING
TO HEAR THAT A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THIS ISSUE BUT ALSO
THE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR TO EACH
OTHER AND I KNOW THE CHAIR AND I
HAVE YOUR CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE ACCOUNTABILITY BUT THAT IT'S
OUR OBLIGATION A RESPONSIBILITY
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING IN SERVING THE
CONSTITUENCIES. THAT NEEDED THE
MOST AS WELL TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ROOM PERHAPS MAYBE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES TO TRAVEL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHEN
APPROPRIATE TO ALSO LEARN ABOUT
THESE AS WELL SO I REAFFIRM MY
COMMITMENT TO HELPING TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE DOING OUR JOB ON THE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY AS
WELL TOO. BUT I ALSO ASKED ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO THINK LONG AND
HARD ABOUT HOW WE CAN GET RID OF
THE RED TAPE BECAUSE THIS IS A
FRUSTRATING PROCESS IN THE OF
COURSE UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH. BUT THAT
ALSO REQUIRES US TO DO OUR JOB
AND OVERSIGHT WHILE MIGHT BE
UNCOMFORTABLE AS WELL SO LET'S
HAVE THESE TOUGH CONVERSATIONS
AND PUT THE EFFORT IN
ACCORDINGLY AND- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VENTURE. THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER JIM
WOOD WHO ALSO SITS ON THE MIDDLE
MILE ADVISORY COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS I DO. SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR
INVITING ME TO BE HERE TODAY- WE
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN LIVING THIS-
FOR AWHILE NOW. AND AND- THEY'LL
BE ANXIOUS TO HEAR THE
PRESENTATIONS TODAY- IT IS- IT
IS A MONUMENTAL TASK- THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US- WE'RE ASKING-
TOO. LARGE AGENCIES THAT DON'T
TYPICALLY WORK TOGETHER. TO WORK
TOGETHER ACTUALLY FORCING THEM
TO WORK TOGETHER- AND THAT ISN'T
WITHOUT CHALLENGES QUITE
FRANKLY- AND- AND ONE OF THE
CONCERNS I HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO. PRESS IS- HOW WE
MEET OUR DEADLINES- THE WORST
THING THAT CAN HAPPEN TO US. IS
TO GET TO THE END OF THE ROAD.
AND NOT HAVE. COMMITTED THE
RESOURCES AND HALF A HALF OF
LOSE IT AND THAT WOULD BE. THAT
WOULD BE A HUGE MONUMENTAL
FAILURE AND WE JUST CAN'T LT
THAT HAPPEN. SO THANK YOU.
EXACTLY ANYBODY ELSE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND START
WITH OUR FIRST PANEL- WHICH IS
TITLED SB ONE FIFTY SIX AND THE
MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND INITIATIVE
WE WILL BE. A WELCOME MEAN-
BRIAN METZGER WHO IS THE
PRINCIPAL FISCAL AND POLICY AND-
ANALISIS FOR PRIVACY. SECURITY
TECHNOLOGY ASSIGNMENT. FOR THE
L. A. O. OR THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSIS. OFFICE WELCOME BRIAN.
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
BRIAN METZGER WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OUR OFFICE WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND INITIATIVE. OPERATION
FOR THE HEARING OUR OFFICE
PREPARE TO HAND OUT THAT WE WILL
SHARE ON SCREEN SO GIVE ME ONE
MOMENT. GREAT MEMBERS AND STAFF
SHOULD ALSO HAVE PRINTED COPIES
OF THE HANDOUT AVAILABLE TO THEM
. STARTING ON PAGE ONE OF THE
HAND OUT WE PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE TOPICS WE WERE ASKED TO
COVER FOR THIS HEARING. THESE
TOPICS INCLUDE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
AGREEMENT REACHED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE DURING LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET PROCESS. SOME GENERAL
INFORMATION ABOUT MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SOME OF THE
COMPONENTS OF SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY SIX WHICH LARGELY
IMPLEMENTS THE AGREEMENT
INCLUSIVE OF A STATE WIDE OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK. ON
THE NEXT PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
CAGE TOO WE PROVIDE A SUMMARY OF
THE SIX BILLION DOLLAR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AGREEMENT. ABOUT
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION OF THE
SIX BILLION TOTAL IS FEDERAL
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN OR A. R. P.
FISCAL RELIEF FUNDS. WITH THE
REMAINDER OF THE FUNDING FROM
THE GENERAL FUND. IT ARPITA
RELIEF FUNDS ARE SUBJECT TO
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SUCH AS THE
ANNUAL RECOVERY PLAN PERFORMANCE
REPORTS AND QUARTERLY PROJECT AN
EXPENDITURE REPORTS. AIR PETE
FUNDS MUST BE ENCUMBERED BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND EXPENDED BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWO TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. THIS SPENDING PLAN
SHOWS HOW THIS FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED AMONG THE THREE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS OR PROGRAMS INCLUDING
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK THAT IS THE
FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING. THE
ENTIRE THREE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION IN FEDERAL A. R. P.
FUNDS FOR THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK WAS APPROPRIATED TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY OR CD T. IN. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. ON PAGE
THREE OF THE HAND OUT WE PROVIDE
DESCRIPTIONS OF EACH OF THE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS AND
IDENTIFY S. B. ONE FIFTY SIX
AGAIN AS THE PRIMARY
IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION FOR THE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
AGREEMENT. ON THE NEXT PAGE OF
THE HANDOUT PAGE FOR WE DESCRIBE
IN BROAD GROUPS THE TYPES OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
ARE RELEVANT TO TODAY'S HEARING
. MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS OFTEN HIGH
CAPACITY FIBER OPTIC CABLES LAID
OVER TENS OR HUNDREDS OF MILES
AT A TIME THAT ONCE CONNECTED TO
BUY AN INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER
OR ISP CAN'T DELIVER LOCAL HIGH
SPEED INTERNET. SO TO ACHIEVE
INCREASED ACCESS TO BROADBAND
SERVICES BY COMMUNITIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS MIDDLE MILE NETWORKS
OFTEN HAVE TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
ISPS TO CONNECT TO. ON PAGE FIVE
OF THE HAND OUT WE PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE NUMBER OF
ESTIMATED ROAD MILES TO BE
COVERED BY THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK. THE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
IS EXPECTED TO BE DEPLOYED
LARGELY ALONG THE STATE'S
HIGHWAYS AND OTHER RIGHTS OF
WAY. ULTIMATELY THE FINAL MIDDLE
MILE PROJECTS IDENTIFIED AND
CONSTRUCTED WILL DETERMINE THE
FINAL NUMBER OF ROAD MILES BUT
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
FOR PURPOSES OF BACKGROUND TO
HAVE THIS NUMBER. WE ALSO
DESCRIBE THE INITIAL EIGHTEEN
PROJECTS SELECTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH TOTAL
BETWEEN EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINE
HUNDRED MILES. WITH PROJECTS IN
DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIC AREAS OF
THE STATE RANGING FROM LESS THAN
TEN MILES TO ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES IN LENGTH. THE
BACKGROUND DOCUMENT FOR THIS
HEARING PROVIDES A LIST OF THESE
PROJECTS FOR YOUR REVIEW. WE
WERE ALSO ASKED TO SUMMARIZE
SOME OF THE EXPECTED BENEFITS OF
A STATE WIDE OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK. SOME EXAMPLES OF
THE BENEFITS DESCRIBED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDE INCREASED
AVAILABILITY OF HIGH SPEED
INTERNET SERVICE TO UNSERVED
INDOOR UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE
STATE. LOWER CONSUMER PRICES FOR
THIS SERVICE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN AREAS WITH BETTER
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET.
THE NEXT PAGE OF THE HANDOUT H.
SIX SUMMARIZES SOME OF THE KEY
MIDDLE MILE RELATED PROVISIONS
OF SB ONE FIFTY SIX. FOR EXAMPLE
SB ONE FIFTY SIX CODIFIES THE
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
STATE GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
INVOLVED IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF MIDDLE MILE NETWORK. AND THE
NEXT PANEL ON THE AGENDA WILL
INCLUDE REPRESENTATIVES FROM A
NUMBER OF THESE ENTITIES. IN
ADDITION THE LAW REQUIRES A
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR TO
MANAGE THE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION- CPUC TO CONSIDER
SOME CRITERIA WHEN IDENTIFYING
PRIORITIZING NETWORK LOCATIONS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION CALTRANS AND
OTHERS BUILDING THE NETWORK TO
USE CERTAIN PROCESS SEES AND
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF CERTAIN
EXEMPTIONS TO EXPEDITE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE NETWORK. PAGE
SEVEN OF THE HANDOUT LISTS THE
ENTITIES INVOLVED IN MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK IMPLEMENTATION. CITY'S
OFFICE OF BROADBAND AND DIGITAL
LITERACY OBI B. D. L. OVERSEES
THE ACQUISITION AND MANAGEMENT
OF CONTRACTS TO DEVELOP AND
CONSTRUCT THE NETWORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. AS WELL AS TO
DEVELOP THE POLICIESPRACTICES
RULES AND STANDARDS FOR
OPERATION AND USE OF THE MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK ONCE CONSTRUCTED.
CPUC HELPS TO IDENTIFY AND
PRIORITIZE THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK LOCATIONS AND THEN
PROVIDES THOSE TO RELEVANT
PARTIES. TO IDENTIFY AND
PRIORITIZE THESE LOCATIONS SI PC
HOW TO SOLICIT AND RECEIVE
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC.
CALTRANS WILL BE A KEY ENTITY IN
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK AS WELL. IT IS OUR
AGREEMENT BETWEEN CALTRANS AND
CD T. TO CONSTRUCT THESE
PROJECTS IS ALREADY IN PLACE. IN
OTHER ENTITIES ON THIS LIST
INCLUDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND TWO OF THE AGENCIES
THAT OVERSEE DEPARTMENTS
RESPONSIBLE FROM IN A MILE
NETWORK ACTIVITIES. THE NEXT
PAGE OF THE HANDOUT PAGE EIGHT
TALKS ABOUT THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CTV'S- B. B.
T. L. ANNOUNCED TO THE
CORPORATION FOR EDUCATION
NETWORK INITIATIVES IN
CALIFORNIA'S SCENIC. AND ITS
MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND INITIATIVE
WOULD BE THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK. NOW REFER TO AS
THE GOLDEN STATE NATS THIS THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR INCLUDES A
NUMBER ADVICE OF ADVISORY BOARD
MEMBERS EXECUTIVE STAFF AND
OTHER SCENIC STAFF WITH
EXPERTISE IN BROADBAND INTERNET
RELATED ISSUES. AGAIN THE ROLE
OF THE THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
IN THIS PROCESS IS VERY
IMPORTANT GOLDEN STATE IN THAT
WILL MANAGE THE DEVELOPMENT
ACQUISITION CONSTRUCTION
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION OF THE
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK WITH
OVERSIGHT FROM CTV'S- BBDO. H.
NINE OF THE HANDOUT TALKS ABOUT
THE BROADBAND ADVISORY COMMITTEE
IDENTIFIED IN STATUTE TO PROVIDE
ADVICE AND GUIDANCE TO ENTITIES
INVOLVED IN THE DEPLOYMENT OF
THE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK. THIS
COMMITTEE IS NOW KNOWN AS THE
MIDDLE MILE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
OR MMA SCENE AND CONSISTS OF
FIVE MEMBERS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND FOR FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. WE PROVIDE THE
CURRENT MEMBERS OF THE MACD
ALTHOUGH AS YOU WILL SEE SOME OF
THE MEMBERS HAVE RECENTLY
CHANGED POSITIONS AND WE WERE
UNABLE TO UPDATE THE HANDOUT- IN
TIME FOR THIS HEARING APOLOGIES
FOR THAT. THE NEXT PAGE OF THE
HANDOUT SIMPLY REFLECTS THE
STATUTORY OBLIGATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HOLD MONTHLY
IN MMA C. MEETINGS. THROUGH THE
FIRST YEAR OF THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK IMPLEMENTATION AND
QUARTERLY THEREAFTER. AND
FINALLY PAGE ELEVEN DESCRIBES
THE ANNUAL LEGISLATIVE REPORT
ALSO REQUIRED BY S. B. ONE FIFTY
SIX TO PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE
WITH INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PROGRESS ON THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK. THIS INFORMATION
INCLUDES THE TOTAL LENGTH OF THE
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK THE LENGTH
CONSTRUCTED OVER THE PRECEDING
QUARTER. THE NUMBER OF ISPS AND
HOUSEHOLDS CONNECTED TO AND
USING THE NETWORK EXPENDITURE
DATA AS WELL AS PROJECTED GOALS
FOR EACH OF THESE MEASURES OVER
THE NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS. THE
FIRST REPORT IS ANTICIPATED TO
BE PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE
BY MARCH FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
EXCELLENT- HANDOUT THAT WE HAVE
HERE- QUITE ROBUST AND I THINK-
IT. DEFINITELY ON YOUR PAGE
ELEVEN LETS USKNOW SOME OF
THOSE QUESTIONS THAT WE ASKED
INITIALLY ABOUT PROGRESS REPORTS
AND SO FAR- WITH THAT I'M GOING
TO OPEN IT UP TO OUR MEMBERS
HERE IF THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MANAGER OF HOPING
THAT YOU MIGHT BILL TO PROVIDE
SOME INSIGHTS AS I WAS TAKING A
LOOK AT THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
BEING PRESENTED TELL ME YOU HAVE
A GRASP AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DIFFERENT EIGHTEEN PILOT
LOCATIONS OF THE CRITERIA THAT
WERE USED A SPECIFICALLY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION-
THAT APPEARS THAT- THERE ARE
NUMBER. OF URBAN AREAS- THAT
BEEN SELECTED AND IN WHICH CASE
THAT WE'VE ACKNOWLEDGED THE FACT
THAT. YOU ARE ATTEMPTING TO
PRIORITIZE UNDERSERVED AREAS IN
THE RURAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL
TOO BUT YOU HELP GIVE SOME
INSIGHT ON WHAT THAT. ON ON ON
THE INSIDE OF SOME BACKGROUND ON
THE CRITERIA. SURE I CAN PROVIDE
SOME INFORMATION AND I KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL ALSO BE
SPEAKING TO THESE PROJECTS- IN
THE NEXT PANEL- BUT IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE CRITERIA
THAT WERE USED. TO DETERMINE
THESE EIGHTEEN PROJECTS WERE
BOTH THE STATUTORY CRITERIA FROM
S. B. ONE FIFTY SIX. ABOUT THE
AREAS THAT. DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
CONNECTIONS- AND ALSO- THAT WERE
REPRESENTATIVE OF A DIVERSE
GROUP OF GEOGRAPHIC AREAS- BUT
THERE WERE OTHER CNSIDERATIONS
AS WELL INCLUDING- TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT THE STATE WOULD
OPERATIONALIZE THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK. INCLUDING CONSTRUCTING
NEW MIDDLE MILE NETWORK- CABLES
ACTUALLY LEASING EXISTING FIBER-
AND ALSO LOOKING AT
INCORPORATING- MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK CONSTRUCTION INTO
EXISTING CALTRANS PROJECTS-
ESSENTIALLY MY UNDERSTANDING WAS
THAT THESE PROJECTS WERE
INTENDED TO SERVICE PILOTS. TO
DEMONSTRATE THE DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT THE STATE THE STATE COULD
ACHIEVE- THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK ACROSS
OF A RANGE OF DIFFERENT- OPTIONS
. IF I MIGHT MANAGER. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I'M SORRY IF I DIDN'T
AND JUST AWFUL OF HIM I MIGHT
PLEASE- AND JUST WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE HATS THE LAWN AND
THE AND THE COMICS THAT WE
SHARED ON THE OVERSIGHT AND THE
IMPORTANCE ALSO THAT MANY OF US
WILL BE ACTUALLY GONE BY
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU OUTLINED SOME OF THAT
TOO AND YOU MIGHT YOU HAVE ANY
IDEAS ON THE APPROACH THAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO TAKE TO HELP
ENSURE. THE APPROPRIATE
IMPLEMENTATION ACCORDINGLY WHILE
WE ARE STILL HERE. THAT IS A
GOOD QUESTION AND SOMETHING WE
HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE INTERESTED IN
MONITORING. IS THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN
ENCUMBERED. AND EXPENDED OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS FOR LAST
MILE PROJECTS I'M SORRY NOT
LET'S NOT PROJECTS MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK PROJECTS- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BEING
PROVIDED. BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AS IT SUBMITS QUARTERLY REPORTS
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- AND
SO WE ARE MONITORING THOSE-
ENCUMBRANCES AND EXPENDITURES.
TO KIND OF TRACK AND SEE WHETHER
OR NOT WE'RE MEETING EXPECTED
TIMELINES. ON THEIR OTHER CAMINO
METRICS THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
BE LOOKED AT SOME OF THEM-
ALREADY INCLUDED IN THE
LEGISLATIVE REPORTS SUCH AS THE-
LENGTH OF THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK THE AMOUNT CONSTRUCTED
OVER THE PRECEDING QUARTER- BUT
I THINK THERE IS DEFINITELY-
SOME VALUE IN LOOKING AT THOSE
EXPENDITURES AND CONFERENCE
NUMBERS. GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU. HOW I JUST UP THE
OBSERVATION ARE PERSONALIZED
APPRECIATE- THE ISSUES THAT YOU
RAISED WITH RESPECT TO THOSE
EIGHTEEN PROJECTS AND HOW THEY
WERE AT. FIRST OF ALL I WANTED
TO DO APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THE PRESIDENT AREA HAS THE-
NEEDS IN THOSE IN THOSE AREAS-
THE THERE IS SOME CONCERN I
THINK FROM THOSE THAT I
REPRESENT THAT. THERE IS A HEAVY
- URBANIZATION IN IT WITH
RESPECT TO SOME OF THE AREAS- I
RAISE IT BECAUSE I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT REALLY
IS AND UNDERSERVED. AND THAT IF
THEIR OPERATIONS OPPORTUNITIES
TO UTILIZE EXISTING PROVIDERS
THAT ARE THERE TO UPGRADE AND TO
COMPLETE THEM- AND FINALLY AYE
AYE I CAN ONLY OBSERVE HAT. WE
JUST SAW PRESENTATION WITH
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF BUREAUCRATIC
GONNA. OVERSIGHT AND SUPPOSEDLY
WORKING TOGETHER AND ALL OF
THAT- THAT BECOMES A REAL
CHALLENGE I THINK TO MOVE OUR
OUR FUNDS QUICKLY AND IN A WAY
WHERE WE DON'T DEBT. WE DON'T
USE THEM IN TIME SO WE LOSE THEM
AYE AYE I WANNA RAISE THIS AGAIN
THAT THE OPERATIONAL. SCHMOOZING
THIS HAS TO BE A PART OF THIS
OUR EXPECTATION NEEDS TO BE.
THAT THEY'RE SAYING YES WE CAN
DO THIS HERE'S WHERE WE WANT TO
GET IT DONE. I'M ALS I DO HOW I
AM HEARING THAT THE SECOND GO
AROUND. OF THAT WE GET PAST THE
EIGHTEEN. IS NOT GOING TO FOCUS-
SIGNIFICANTLY ON THE UNDERSERVED
AREAS AND SOME OF THE RURAL
AREAS A LITTLE MORE. EFFECTIVELY
I THINK SO I WANT TO APPRECIATE
THAT- AND- MY VOICE HERE WILL.
WILL BE FOR THOSE AREAS THAT ARE
REALLY UNDERSERVED VERY
EXPENSIVE TO GET TO THAT TO THAT
LAST MILE THE MIDDLE MILE HELPS
BUT AT THE END OF ALL OF THIS. I
HAVE A LOT OF. SCHOOLS THAT
DON'T HAVE INTERNET OUT IN THE
RURAL AREAS A LOT OF
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS THAT
CANNOT CONNECT- AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THE IN THE INTERFACE
BETWEEN THE OF THAT WILD. FIRE
AREAS AND THE URBAN URBANIZATION
AREAS WHERE THERE ARE CONCERNS
OVER RELIABILITY IN THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS SO. I REALLY
APPRECIATE. WHERE WE'RE HEADED.
I DO WANT TO REMIND US THAT SB
ONE FIVE SIX REALLY WAS VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THE UNSERVED AREAS
AND I THINK WE GOT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING.
WE'RE NOT OVERBUILDING AND THAT
WE'RE GETTING IT DONE BECAUSE I
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE LIMITED
RESOURCES WITH A VERY. BIG PRICE
TAG AND SO I'M HOPING BY THE END
OF THE DAY. WILL BE ABLE TO SIT
HERE AND SAY WE GET IT- INSTEAD
OF WHAT HAPPENED ALONG THE WAY.
DID THIS TURN INTO A- THE
BUREAUCRATIC NIGHTMARE THAT-
MADE BIG PROMISES BUT COULDN'T
KEEP THOSE PROMISES TO THE
PEOPLE. OUT WE DO HAVE
BUREAUCRACIES IN THE STATE. THAT
HAVE OPERATED IN SUCH A WAY THAT
THEY HAVE MADE BIG PROMISES AND
IF NOT PERFORMED. AND I BELIEVE
THAT PART OF THE CONCERNED WE
OUGHT TO BE RACING HERE. IS THAT
WE HAVE THE P. YOU SEE AND WE
HAVE THE- THE DEPARTMENT OF-
TECHNOLOGY. AND MY EXPERIENCE
HERE. HAS BEEN. THAT THOSE TWO
ENTITIES ARE. SOMETIMES LESS
THAN RELIABLE. AND I THINK WE'VE
GOT TO RECOGNIZE THAT AND BE A
CHEERLEADER NOT JUST A POINTING
FINGER BUT A CHEERLEADER FOR
THEM. TO DO THIS IN A
STREAMLINED WAY IN A WAY THAT
SAYS YES NOT NO WAITER MAY BE.
AND- THANK YOU I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE FACT THAT THERE'S SOME
CONSENSUS HERE THAT. WE CAN MOVE
IN THESE DIRECTIONS. I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING WE'RE GONNA
KEEP REPEATING I KNOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILL- WOULD DENY AS-
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE MIDDLE
MILE WE HAVE SAID THIS MANY
TIMES AND THAT'S OUR EXPECTATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. BUT MRMETZGER
EVEN SB ONE FIFTY SIX. IN THE
LANGUAGE IT SAYS THAT THE
COMMISSION SHALL UPDATE THE
LOCATIONS OF THE MIDDLE MILE
PROJECTS FROM TIME TO TIME AS
THE COMMISSION DEEMS
APPROPRIATE. NO THAT FIRST
EIGHTEEN PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED. AND IT APPEARS AT
LEAST FROM A HAND OUT THE THREE
POINT TWO FIVE BILLION WAS A HAS
BEEN ALLOCATED TO TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THE DOES THAT MEAN
THAT THE THREE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION IS FOR THOSE EIGHTEEN
PROJECTS. R ARE WE EXPECTING TO
HAVE THE ADDITIONAL PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED. QUESTION THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION WE ARE
EXPECTING TO HAVE THE ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS IDENTIFIED THE THREE
POINT TWO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IS THE TOTAL FUNDING AMOUNT. FOR
THE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK THOSE
EIGHTEEN PROJECTS REPRESENT A
SMALL PORTION OF THAT AMOUNT-
THE FUNDING WAS APPROPRIATED IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUT IS
AVAILABLE FOR ENCUMBRANCE AND
TELL DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND
AVAILABLE FOR EXPENDITURE
EXPENDITURE AND TELL DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SIX
SO THE ADDITIONAL PROJECTS THAT
ARE ANTICIPATED TO BE IDENTIFIED
BELL BEAT EARLY AS NEXT MONTH.
I'M WOULD BE USING THE THREE
POINT. TWO FIVE. ON WHAT THESE
INITIAL EIGHTEEN PROJECTS WILL
COST OF THE THREE POINT TWO
FIVE. I HAVE NOT SEEN THAT
ESTIMATES BUT IT IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING YOU COULD REQUEST FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION I BELIEVE
THAT WOULD HAPPEN NUMBER. THANK
YOU MR MUSK. YES ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE MOVE ON I
THANK YOU MR METZGER- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR ROBUST REPORT TO
AND- WE WILL BE MOVING TO OUR
NEXT PANEL HERE OUR NEXT PANEL
HAS SEVERAL A PRESENTER SO I
WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF
POSSIBLE WILL HEAR ALL OF THEM
THERE ARE ACTUALLY SIX
PRESENTERS- AND THEN WE WOULD
ENGAGE AND QUESTIONS AFTERWARDS
SO OUR NEXT- PANEL IS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MIDDLE
MILE BROADBAND INITIATIVE AS OF
THIS BEEN STATED THEY ARE ALL.
ARE A MULTIPLE AGENCIES WORKING
ON THIS TOGETHER AND UP QUITE A
LOT OF PLAYERS HERE SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THEY CAN EACH TALK
ABOUT THEIR EXPERTISE- I'VE HAD
A CHANCE NOW TO MEET WITH ALL OF
THEM OUR FIRST PRESENTER NOW IS
AMY TONG DIRECTOR OF OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION AND ACTUALLY
SINCE I'VE STARTED THIS ROLE SHE
HAS HAD A TWO OR THREE WEEKS
CHANGES AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
HER- EXPERTISE HERE. AMY GOOD
MORNING OF EVERYONE IN THE CHAIR
COURTS OVER VICE CHAIR PATTERSON
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
SORRY- I'M SORRY AMY CAN I JUST
INTRODUCED THE REST OF THE
PEOPLE JUST QUICKLY- THAT ARE ON
THE PANEL AND THEN WE'LL COME
BACK SO. WE HAVE AMY TONG
DIRECTOR OF OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION SCOTT ADAMS DEPUTY-
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OFFICE OF
BROADBAND DIGITAL LITERACY FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. MARK MONROE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE BROADBAND MIDDLE
MILE INITIATIVE. ROBERT OSBORNE
BORN DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICATIONS
DIVISIONS OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION JANICE
BENTON CHIEF DIVISION OF DESIGN
CALTRANS AND TONI NOT AND
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER OF THE GOLDEN STATE NET
THEY WILL ALL BE PRESENT IN. A
BACK TO AMY. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
I GOOD MORNING AGAIN CHAIR OF
GROUPS OVER MY SPARE PATTERSON
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY- WE KNOW
THAT A RELIABLE BROADBAND
CONNECTION MAKES THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN HAVING ACCESS TO FOOD
SERVICE HEALTHCARE EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT. BOB SOMETIME YOU
KNOW GOING WITHOUT. AND YET MANY
CALIFORNIANS STILL DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT DATE. THAT IS WHY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS MADE
BROADBAND FOR ALL ONE OF HIS TOP
PRIORITIES HE KNOWS HOW
IMPORTANT ACCESS AFFORDABILITY
AND DIGITAL EQUITY AND
INCLUSION. ARE TO MOVE FROM
SURVIVING TO THRIVING IN THE
MODERN WORLD. IT IS TIME TO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND WE
ARE PRIVILEGED TO HAVE THE
BACKING OF OUR GOVERNOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THIS DREAM A
REALITY. WE NOW HAVE BEEN MISTER
FUNDING IN PLACE TO MAKE THE
TANGIBLE PROGRESS ON THE KEY
COMPONENT OF DELIVERING ON
PROMISES OF BROADBAND FOR ALL. I
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO GIVE A
SPECIAL THANKS TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF COURT SOBRE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM WHAT SENATOR AT. A
GONZALEZ AND SENATOR MCGUIRE FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS AND SERVING ON
THE VERY FIRST THING TOMORROW
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. I ALSO LIKE
TO THANK OUR PARTNERS FROM CPUC
CALTRANS GOLDEN STATE NOT AS A
THIRD PARTY PART OF MINISTRY TO
T. PA. IN SUPPORT FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GOVERNMENT
AGENCY TELLS THE AGENCY TO
PROVIDE WITH A OF A PARTNERSHIP
AND CONTINUED. SUPPORT SYSTEM
FOR THIS HUGE ENDEAVOR. IN MY
BROADBAND INITIATIVE WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT
WITHOUT YOUR DEDICATION SUPPORT
AND HARD WORK SB ONE FIFTY SIX.
I KNOW AS THE VICE CHAIR HAVE
MENTIONED EARLIER THERE SEEMS TO
BE A LOT OF THE ENTITY IN THE
PHOTOGRAPHY HOW DO WE MAKE THIS
WORK. AND AS MANY OF YOU
PROBABLY HAVE HEARD THAT BY NOW-
STARTING MARCH. I WILL BE THE
NEW INCOMING SECRETARY OF
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY AND
EVEN NOW IN MY CURRENT ROLE AS
THE- A DIRECTOR OF OFFICE
DIGITAL INNOVATION I CONTINUE TO
SERVE AS A SENIOR ADVISER TO THE
BROADBAND INITIATIVES IMPOSED
MARCH I WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
MEMBER OF THE MMA C. AND A
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP. FOR BROADBAND FOR
ALL THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS GOING TO
BE A STREAMLINED PROCESS AND
ABILITY TO MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY.
AS THE VICE CHAIRS EXPLICITLY
CALLED OUT SO THAT WE CAN ALL
ACHIEVE THIS DREAM OF CLOSING
THE DIGITAL. DIVIDE SOONER THAN
LATER. TELL TO STE BOB. OFFICE
WILL BE A SINGLE POINT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR BROADBAND FOR
ALL AND YOU WILL HEAR FROM MANY
OF THEM INCLUDING OUR PARTNERS
AND HOW THEY WENT- CARRIED THIS
IMPORTANT MISSION FORWARD.
BEFORE I GO FURTHER I LIKE TO
EXPLAIN THE TAP TERMS BUT WILL
BE TALKING ABOUT AND YOU WILL BE
HEARING THROUGHOUT THE REST OF
THE PRESENTATION THE WITH THAT
NICK IF YOU COULD GO AHEAD. AND
PROVIDE THE FLIGHT. YOU CAN GO
IN ADVANCE. YEAH THE MIDDLE MILE
AND LAST MILE PROVIDE THE
PHYSICAL WORK TO DELIVER SERVICE
TO EVERY CALIFORNIANS. HELLO MY
IF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CONNECTS
TO GLOBAL INTERNET THE LAST MY-
REPRESENT A CONNECTION OUR
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER ISPS
PROVIDE TO PEOPLE DOORSTEP AND
DEVICES. WHAT WE HAVE A FORTY
DEVELOPMENTAL MODEL WITH LAST
MILE CONNECTION CALIFORNIA WILL
HAPPEN TO DELIVER BROADBAND FOR
ALL. INVESTITURE STATED EARLIER
HAVING BOTH THE MIDDLE MILE AND
LAST MILE WORKING TOGETHER IT'S
IMPERATIVE. TODAY WE'RE HERE TO
TELL YOU MORE ABOUT THE MIDDLE
MILE BROADBAND INITIATIVE THAT%
X. EXPENDITURES THAT IS TO
EXPAND BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ADOPTION. AND IS DEFINED IN
SECTION ONE FIFTY SIX THE MIDDLE
MILE ADVISORY COMMITTEE MONITORS
DEVELOPMENT IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK- PLEASE THE BAND'S. AND
AS THE- COMMITTEE HAVE MET OF
STARTING IN AUGUST TO ACHIEVE
THIS ACCESS AND AFFORDABLE AND
OPTION TO CLOSE TWO SO ENSURE
DIGITAL EQUITY AND INCLUSION THE
VERY FIRST TASK OF THE COMMITTEE
AFTER WE STARTED MEETING IN
AUGUST WITH TO IDENTIFY GUIDING
PRINCIPLES TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
STAYING FOCUSED ON MOVING
FORWARD. IN THE SEPTEMBER AND
AMAZING MEETING- THE THREE
PRINCIPLES WERE ADOPTED. PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE
MILE BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
BEING ABLE OF LAST MILE NETWORK
CONNECTIVITY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. BILL THE NETWORK
EXPEDITIOUSLY LEVERAGING
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE NETWORKS
AND CONSTRUCTION PROJECT WHERE
FEASIBLE. PRIORITIZE
CONNECTIVITY TO UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY INCLUDING
COMMUNITY INSTITUTIONS. AS OF
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE. B.
AFTER HAVE IDENTIFYING TO
INITIAL EIGHTEEN LOCATIONS THAT
REPRESENT EXCELLENT BALANCE OF
PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION. LOCATION
THAT REPRESENT URBAN AND RURAL
AREAS UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
AND THAT CAN BE START QUICKLY
AND THAT EMPLOYS A VARIETY OF
CONSTRUCTION AND LEASE METHODS.
DESIGN AND EVALUATION WORK HAS
BEGUN WHICH IS THE FIRST STEP
VERY SOON WILL BE ROLLING OUT
THE FULL LIST OF PROJECT
LOCATION AND THE SEQUENCE OF
WORK IN ADDITION TO THE STATE Y.
MAP THAT WAS POSTED AS OF
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST THIRTY
FIRST OF LAST YEAR. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IT IS EXCITING TO
HAVE HIT THE GROUND RUNNING AND
SEE THIS PROJECT UNFOLDS AS IN
SUCH INCREDIBLE SHAPE PERIOD. OF
TIME. YOUR RECOGNITION OF HOW
IMPORTANT BROADBAND IS TO
CALIFORNIA IT'S RESIDENT
BUSINESS WILL ULTIMATELY ENSURE
THE POSSIBILITY OF AN IN HOME
CONNECTION FOR EVERYONE WHO
WANTS IT. WE HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE PRESENTATION
COMING UP NEXT. WEEKEND TO SHOP
WITH POTENTIAL PROGRESS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
THE NEXT PRESENTER SCOTT ADAMS
WHO'S GONNA BE UP KICKING OFF
THE PRESENTATION. IT'S GOT.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR TOM YOUR
QUICK SILVA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IN THE PUBLIC- IF YOU
ADVANCE TO THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE
. IS DIRECTOR TOM NOTED
BROADBAND FOR ALL THESE THE
NEWSMEN MINISTRATIONS OVER
PROGRAM TO CLOSE CALIFORNIA'S
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND FOSTER
DIGITAL EQUITY AND INCLUSION IN
THE STATE. OFFICE OF BROADBAND
AND DIGITAL LITERACY OVERSEES
THIS PROGRAM IN COORDINATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PROPPING
COUNCIL AND ITS MEMBER ENTITIES
AND IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BROADBAND EXECUTIVE
ORDER THE BROADBAND FOR ALL
ACTION PLAN. AND IN THE
OVERSEEING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE STATE WIDE OPEN ACCESS
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK- WOULD POINT
OUT THAT THE TWELVE MEMBER
CALIFORNIA BROADBAND COUNCIL WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
TO PROMOTE BROADBAND ADOPTION
AND DEPLOYMENT AND UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED. AREAS OF THE STATE
IS DEFINED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. THE
COUNCIL HISTORICALLY IDENTIFIED
STATE RESOURCES AND COURAGEOUS
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
RECOMMENCED STRATEGIC POLICY. TO
ESTABLISH. AFFECTED STRUCK FOR
PROVIDING CLASS HIGH SPEED
ACCESS THROUGHOUT COME TO
SUPPORT EDUCATION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE INTO THE
CREASE AFFORDABILITY AND DIGITAL
LITERACY. WANTED TO- YOU KNOW
IT'S IN A SLIDE DEPICTS THAT IN
RESPONSE YOU COVETED- YEAH IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ISSUED. EXECUTIVE ORDER I
ENDED UP SEVENTY THREE DASH
TWENTY TO REFOCUS THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
DIRECTED THE BROADBAND COUNCIL
TO DEVELOP A NEW STATEWIDE
BROADBAND ACTION PLAN TO PROMOTE
DIGITAL EQUITY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WITHIN FOUR MONTHS
OF THE EXACT ORDER THE BROADBAND
COUNCIL RELEASED AFTER ALL
ACTION PLAN IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY- TO RETREAT IN
LONG TERM GOALS FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST IS TO CREATE ACCESS TO
HIGH PERFORMANCE BROADBAND HOME
SCHOOLS LIBRARIES BUSINESSES AND
EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE. ARE
EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE SORRY
ABOUT THAT- THE SECOND IS TO
MAKE AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE
BROADBAND. SERVICE AND DEVICES
NECESSARY TO ACCESS THE INTERNET
AND THE LAST ONES TO PROVIDE
AVENUES FOR TRAINING AND SUPPORT
TO ENABLE DIGITAL INCLUSION.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. I HAS BEEN
NOTED BY A NUMBER OF PEOPLE-
THEY DID NEW INITIATIVES
OUTLINED IN THE HISTORIC- SB ONE
FIFTY SIX AND FUNDED BY THIRD.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWO STATE
BUDGET INCLUDING THE MIDDLE
MILE. AND LAST MILE INITIATIVES
LED BY C. T. AND THE BROADBAND
OFFICE AND THAT CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
RESPECTIVELY- AND DONE A GREAT
DEAL TO. BUILD ON AUGMENTIN
SUPPORT THE WORK OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUT I THINK COUNCIL.
AND I WILL HAND OVER TO
PRESENTATION TO MY COLLEAGUE
MARK IN ROUND. OUR MEMBERS WE
CAN GET YOU COPIES OF THIS
PRESENTATION- FIRM WILL MAKE
SURE YOU GET THIS PRINTED.
ANYBODY NEED ONE RIGHT NOW THAT
DOESN'T HAVE ONE. OKAY SORRY ALL
RIGHT THE THIRD- THANK YOU TO
DIRECTOR ADAM- IN THE MORNING
MEMBERS ARE MARK MEMBER THAT IF
YOU DIRECT AT T. FOR THE MIDDLE
BROAD INITIATIVE. WAS CREATED BY
S. B. ONE FIFTY FOUR AND FUNDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE- BUDGET
ACT. SO REMOVED TO THE NEXT
SLIDE- SB ONE FORTY SIX-
ASSIGNED TO SPECIFIC ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES- RELATIVE TO
THIS PROJECT- T. OVERSEES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM OTHERS INCLUDE MANAGING
THE FUNDS REPORTING PROGRESS IN
MEETING YOU AGREEMENTS WITH THE
OTHER PARTNERS ON THE PROJECT-
ASSEMBLY AT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ROLE IS TO-
IDENTIFIED ON CERTAIN-
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BY
GATHERED INFORMATION FROM-
TELECOM COMPANIES AND- AND
PUBLIC COMMENTS TO INFORM HOW
BEST TO REACH THE COMMUNITIES
WITH THAT WITH THE GREATEST
NEED. L. SB ONE PROCESS ALSO
BOUGHT SB ONE FIFTY SIX ALSO
PROVIDES FOR A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR Q. THE WILL MANAGE
AND DEVELOP THE OVERALL SYSTEM
INCLUDING SYSTEM LEVEL DESIGN
IDENTIFICATION OF EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS AVAILABLE
FOR LEASES- AS WELL AS THE
EVENTUAL MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATION OF THE SYSTEM- CDT HAS
SIGNED A CONTRACT WITH GOLDEN
STATE AT. THE SERVICE. THIS
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR- THANK
YOU IT IS IT'S ALSO PROVIDE A-
CAL TO IS- REALLY GIVING THE
MAJORITY THE DESIGN IN THE- OF
THE SAID. SO THE PLAN PERMIT AND
WORK SURVEYING. AND CONTRACTING
WITH COME UP WITH CONSTRUCTION
COMPANIES TO ACTUALLY BUILD THE
MAJORITY OF THE SYSTEM. ARE THE
LESLIE ARE PROVIDE FOR-
DEPARTMENT FINANCED- TO PROVIDE
UP IN THE BUDGET OVERSIGHT AND
QUARTERLY REPORTING ON THE ON
THE PROGRESS OF THE PROJECT- TO
THE TO THE IN THE USE OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE U. S.
TREASURE. NEXT SLIDE. SHE SO I'M
THESE ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT THE MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND
INITIATIVE PROJECT RECOMMENDED
THE I. AS WE RECENTLY REPORTED
REFERENCE THAT IS A FLOW UNDER
WATER AND THAT WE'LL SEE HOW
THIS WILL BE TO- SOME OF A
BACKLOADED EXPENDITURE PATTERN
THIS INVOLVES THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION HOLDING A
PUBLIC PROCEEDING TO GET PUBLIC
INPUT ON THE PROJECT INCLUDING
WHERE LIKE THE GREATEST AREAS OF
BEANS IN THE STATE ARE.
INCLUDED- WHAT ABOUT THE- WOULD
TURN OUT WITH GOLDEN THAT AND
CALTRAIN TO THIS ENGINEER THIS.
FROM DIGITAL REGARD HOW MUCH
CONDUIT- THE FREQUENT OF ALL TO
THAT THE TO THE LARGER STATE
SINCE LEVEL DESIGN FOR THE
BROADER NETWORK- THIS ALSO
INVOLVES- SAID THE NETWORK IS
BETTER IDENTIFIED AND DEFINED-
AND- WE ARE BOTH ABOUT THE-
IDENTIFIED. LOCATIONS AND BUILD
LOCATIONS IN CALTRANS WILL BEGIN
ITS PRE CONSTRUCTION AND
CONSTRUCTION WORK. WHAT WITH ALL
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS
NECESSARILY BEING SIGNED BY
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. I
MOVED TO THE NEXT FIVE. SO- AS
NOTED THAT SB ONE FIFTY SIX
ASSIGNS THESE THESE ROLES- FOR
THE BERRIES PARTNERS- IT'S A
CONSISTENT WITH THESE ROLES- CD
KEY ON HAS STIRRED UP THE
PROGRAMS PASSED THE JULY AND
AUGUST ARE STARTING TO HOLD
MONTHLY- MIDDLE MILE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEETINGS- YOU SEE HAS
A COMPLETED IT'S PROCEEDING ON
THE- PROGRAM. IN SEPTEMBER AND
PROVIDED AN UPDATED MAP BY THE
END OF DECEMBER- STATING THAT
AND- THE CALTRANS ARE CURRENTLY
COORDINATING ON THE DESIGN OF
THE PROJECT AND THE OVERALL
SYSTEM LEVEL DESIGN. THE COUNTRY
IS DOING A PRE CONSTRUCTION WORK
ON THE INITIAL EIGHTEEN PROJECTS
AND THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATORS
IS WORKING ON ALTERNATIVES TO
DEVELOP THESE ARE PROJECTS INTO
THE BROADER NETWORK. I'M AS
PROJECTS- BUT FOR THE BROADER.
LEVEL IS COMPLETED AND THE
SECOND- TO REBUILD IT YOU START
HANNAH BUY THIS CAL PULLED FOR
WITH. CONSTRUCTION AND THE
GOLDEN STATE YEAH WELL I DO.
WAITING WHERE THE- AGREE LISA. I
NEED BE MADE TO- OKAY IT ABOUT
THAT THE- SYSTEM. AS THAT IS
BUILT OPERATE IN MAKING WE ARE
IN THE IN THIS- WILL BE DONE BY
THE THIRD PER ADMINISTRATOR. AT
THE NOTE THAT WHILE ALL OF THE
ASKED OF THE PROJECT. ADDRESSING
FOR COMMUNITY ONLY WHEN THE
COMMUNITY HAVE A LOT MILE CA. SO
THIS BROADBAND PACKAGE ALSO
INCLUDES TWO POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS ADDRESS
IT IS LAST MILE MEET AS THAT. AS
KYLIE NOTED- AND DOUBT CAN YOU
SEE IS A REGISTRY IS FUNDS THE
MIDDLE MILE PROJECTS WILL NEED
TO BE COORDINATED WITH THE CAN
YOU SEE- AND THEIR. WORK WITH
THE LAST MILE. READ TO THE NEXT
SLIDE. SO THAT'S THIS CHART HERE
ARE YOU REALLY MENTALES THE
PATTERN IN BY ONE SIX AND A ROOF
THE THREE POINT TWO FIVE DOLLARS
THAT WAS APPROPRIATED TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND AS CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTS ARE SIGNED- THE
REMAINING AMOUNT AVAILABLE GOES
DOWN WHILE THE AMOUNT SPENT A
GOES UP. AND SO THIS REALLY
REFLECTS THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
UP FRONT COST SUPPORT COSTS FOR
CD KEY YOU SEE CALTRANS AND
GOLDEN STATE NAP OUR- RELATIVELY
SMALL- COMPONENTS CARE COMPARED
TO THE BROADER- COST OF THE
PROJECT. NON TO THE VAST
MAJORITY THE FUNDS WILL BE SPENT
ON CONSTRUCTION OF THE SYSTEM
AND LEASE AGREEMENTS AND THESE
BONTA SAID EARLIER CURRENTLY OUT
YEARS AS CONSTRUCTION RAMPS UP
AFTER CALTRANS COMPLETES PRE
CONSTRUCTION WORK AND AS A
NETWORK. COMPONENTS FROM ONLINE
. IN FRONT OF THE NET. FIVE THE
HOBBIT BY THE L. A. A. M. B. I.
ON ARE PROVIDED SO SOME OF YOU
MAY ALSO BE INCREASINGLY FROM
WITH THE REV TO THE CRIME BY
RIGHT OF STATE FISCAL BRICK
FINDER SFR AFT- IT'S A- WHICH IS
NOT. HOW EXPECT ARE BEING
TRACKED IN REPORTED THAT OF
FINANCE. THE FEDERAL MUST
ENCUMBER LETTER ELSE YEAH.
BURGER CO BY DECEMBER TWENTY TWO
FOUR AND BE STE ON COMPETE-
PROJECT BY TWO TWENTY. THE BAY
ON INITIAL AS THE THAT YOU'RE
TWO FOR BILLION FOR ESTIMATED TO
BE ENOUGH CONSTRUCT RAFI THAT
MILE OF. THE HOUSE MILES. TO
MAKE A THE DIFFERENCE SB ONE
FIFTY SIX PROVIDE FOR THE USE OF
OUR SIX YOU SPEAK UP JUST A
LITTLE BIT PLEASE SORRY.
ABSOLUTELY IS THIS ALL RIGHT.
YEAH A LITTLE MAYBE THANK YOU
OKAYABSOLUTELY I TO MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE SB ONE FIFTIES
PROVIDES FOR THE USE OF LEASE
AGREEMENTS TO FILL THE GAP IN
THE SHORT RUN SO THAT OUR
NETWORK IS OPERATIONAL BY
DECEMBER TWENTY SIX AND BY THE
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S
FEDERAL DEADLINE. NEXT FIVE. SO
AS NOT TO BE ONE FIFTY SIX
PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT ROLE FOR-
PCP COULD HELP. IT IS OF NEW IN
THIS FOLLOWING THE P. PA COMMENT
THIS SEPT AND PRIOR TO
COMPLETION OF THE BROADER
STATEWIDE MAP THAT WAS POSTED IN
DECEMBER ACCUSING HELP CITY KEY
UP BY EIGHTEEN PROJECTS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO START ON
AND- BEGIN OUR LEARNING PROCESS
THESE PROJECTS REPRESENT
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FARM
FEATHER ATTENDED POPULATIONS AND
URBAN RURAL AND TRIBAL AREAS.
SOME WILL SUPPORT- THE
CONNECTIVITY BY CONNECTING THE
COR TO THE LAST MILE LOCATIONS
AND OTHERS WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF JOINT BUILD OPPORTUNITIES
WITH EXISTING TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS. THE PROJECTS WILL HAVE
TO GIVE GOLDEN STATE AT THE END
OF A CHANCE TO EXPLORE THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND MECHANICS OF
USING LEASE AGREEMENTS SUCH AS I
ARE USED TO CONNECT COMMUNICATE
COMMUNITIES TO THE CORE. HERE
THE SEGMENTS. THANKS A LOT. ALL
RIGHT SO FINAL POINT OFF WITH A
THAT POINT MEMBERS TO THE MIDDLE
MILE INITIATIVE WEBSITE- WHICH
WILL PROVIDE A PROJECT UPDATES
AS THEY BECOME AVAILABLE- SINCE
THE SINCE THE MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND INITIATIVE WAS PASSED
WE HAVE A WITH STOOD UP THE MMA
SEE THE METABOLIC VISOR
COMMITTEE WHICH MEETS MONTHLY
FOR THE FIRST YEAR TO PROVIDE
UPDATES ON THE PROJECT TO THE-
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC AND TO RECEIVE INPUT FROM
BOTH OF THEM- WE'VE ALSO- SIGNED
AGREEMENTS WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION CALTRANS TO
GOLDEN STATE IN THAT. A RELATIVE
TO THEIR ROLES AS SPECIFIED IN
SB ONE FIFTY SIX- WE'VE WORKED
WITH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IN THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR TO DEVELOP AND
ANNOUNCED EIGHTEEN INITIAL
PROJECTS THAT REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY 10% OF THE OVERALL
SYSTEM AND AS WE DESIGN THESE
PROJECTS WE ARE CONTINUING TO
LEARN ABOUT THE COST SCHEDULE
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION OF THE
SYSTEM AS CALTRANS MOVES FORWARD
WITH THE PRE CONSTRUCTION WORK.
AND THAT WE POSTED A TNCS
UPDATED MAPS ON OUR WEBSITE THIS
PAST DECEMBER SO TO SUMMARIZE
OUR CD KEY IS- IS DEFINITELY
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE MIDDLE
MILE BROADBAND INITIATIVE
PROJECT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
SUCCESSFULLY PARTNERING WITH THE
ENTITIES IDENTIFIED AS THE ONE
FIFTY SIX STARTING STARTED SOME
PROJECTS AHEAD OF TIME PROVIDING
FOR TRANSPARENCY- THROUGH THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND OUR
WEBSITE AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO
COMPLETE THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT
BY THE FEDERAL DEADLINES AND
BRINGING IN- THIS IMPORTANT
EQUITY PROJECT TO CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE.
SO WITH THAT- I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO ROB OSBORNE THE DIRECTOR
OF COMMUNICATIONS. AT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. THANK YOU
MORE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR CORK SO
AND THE TIME MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR INVITING THE C. HERE TODAY
TO. NOT ON OUR MILE IN
COORDINATION WITH OUR AGENCIES.
I'M ROBERT OSBORNE DIRECTOR THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. THE PASSAGE OF SB
ONE FIFTY SIX THE CPC IS BEEN
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN WORK AND
COMPLETING THE MIDDLE MILE
ANALYSIS WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
IMPLEMENTING THE LAST MILE
BROADBAND PROGRAMS. THE BLUE BOX
ON THE LEFT HIGHLIGHTS THE CPUC
MIDDLE MILE RESPONSIBILITIES
UNDER SB ONE FIFTY SIX. WHICH
INCLUDES IDENTIFYING ROUTES AND
PRIORITY AREAS. SOLICITING
PUBLIC COMMENT ON PROPOSED
ROUTES AND REPORTING THE
FINALITY TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY FOR USE IN
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION AND
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT. THE GREEN
BOX IN THE MIDDLE HIGHLIGHTS THE
CPC'S RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND LAST MILE FUNDING.
CPC WILL SOON RELEASE A PROPOSED
DECISION WITH THE FINAL THE
FINAL PROGRAM RULES AND FUNDING
ALLOCATION. THE ORANGE BOX ON
THE RIGHT HIGHLIGHTS OTHER
SUPPORTING BROADBAND PROGRAMS
THIS INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND. THE LOAN
LOSS RESERVE PROGRAM AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THE CPC
CURRENTLY HAS NO OUTSTANDING
CASF GRANT REQUEST AND IS
IMPLEMENTING NEW PROGRAM ROLES
AS DIRECTED BY SB ONE FIFTY SIX
AB FOURTEEN AND THAT'S BEFORE.
STAFF IS CURRENTLY DRAFTING A
LOW LOTS RESERVE STAFF PROPOSAL
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. IN JANUARY
THE CDC RELEASED PROPOSED
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. SCHEDULED
FOR ABOUT ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FOURTH. THE CDC WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL UPDATES ON OUR LAST
MOMENT WOMAN PATIENT AT OUR LAST
MILE HEARINGS LATER THIS SPRING. AS RICARDO NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THAT'S REQUIRED IN SB ONE FIFTY
SIX THE CPC HAD NINETY DAYS TO
SOLICIT AND RECEIVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON INITIALLY PROPOSED
THE MILE PROJECT LOCATIONS
ROUTES AND NETWORK DESIGN.
PUBLIC COMMENTS RESPONDED TO TWO
RULINGS IN REAL MAKING TWENTY
DASH ZERO NINE DASH ZERO ZERO
ONE. US TWO RULINGS ON THE FIRST
WEEK IN AUGUST SIX. THAT RULING
REQUESTED INPUT ON MIDDLE MY
LOCATIONS AND THEN SEPTEMBER
NINTH WHICH FOCUSED ON NETWORK
CHARACTERISTICS. DURING THIS
PROCESS OVER A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS COMMENTED WE
RECEIVED SIXTY FORMAL COMMENTS
AND MORE THAN THIRTY INFORMAL
COMMENTS. ELABORATE A BIT FORMAL
COMMENTS MAY BE MADE BY PARTIES
TO A PROCEEDING AND INFORMAL
COMMENTS BEING BE MADE BY ANYONE
WITHOUT REQUIRING A PERSON TO
BECOME AN ANTI BECOME A PARTY. A
PERSON OR ENTITY WE RECEIVED
OVER THIRTY COMMENTS FROM LOCAL
ENTITIES INCLUDING CITY COUNTY.
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS REGIONAL
CONSORTIA AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WOULD RECEIVE AROUND TWENTY
COMMENTS FROM TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS AND OVER TWENTY
COMMENTS FROM NONPROFIT AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
BUT DAVID EARLIER SB ONE FIFTY
SIX GAME OF THE CDC NINETY DAYS
FROM ITS PASSAGE OR UNTIL
OCTOBER TWENTY FIRST TO SOLICIT
FORMAL PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE W CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
AND ACCEPT INFORMAL PUBLIC
COMMENTS. CLYDE PLEASE. P. FIFTY
PER PUBLIC COMMENTATOR TO CREATE
A MAP THAT OVERLAYS BOTH FORMAL
AND INFORMAL PUBLIC COMMENTS
OVER THE CPC'S ORIGINAL PROPOSED
ROUTES. THIS INTERACTIVE MAP
PROVIDES THE PUBLIC WITH THE WAY
TO VISUALIZE THE PROPOSED ROUTE
CHANGES AND SEE THEIR PUBLIC
COMMENTS MAPPED OUT IN RELATION
TO OTHERS. IMAGE THAT WE SEE
HERE ON THE SLIDE FOR THE
SCREENSHOT ABOVE THE MAP THE
INDENTATION COUNTY. GREEN LINE
AS YOU'LL SEE ON BOTH ON THE
LEFT IN THE CENTER. I CHAU
PROPEL PROPOSED ROUTE ADDITIONS
COMING FROM THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE INTERACTIVE
MAP YOU CAN SELECT A SEGMENT.
AND POP UP A POP UP PROVIDES
INFORMATION ON HIS SUGGESTED THE
ROUTE CHANGE WHAT WAS SUGGESTED
IN THE LATE THE PUBLIC COMMENT-
IF I COMPOSITOR THE PERSON-
SHOWING THE SLIDES IF YOU COULD
PLEASE- THANK YOU. AT WE COULD
SEE IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT- THE
DAN MILLER CHAIR OF THE NEVADA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
RECOMMENDED THAT THE SEGMENT
CONNECTING HIGHWAY FORTY NINE
HIGHWAY TWENTY BE ADDED TO THAT
ABOUT WRAPS. THIS MAP WAS MADE
PUBLIC IN JANUARY AND IS
AVAILABLE ON THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT ON MY WEBSITE
UNDER THE DATA AND ANALYSIS TAP
. AT FLIGHT PLEASE. IN ADDITION
TO REQUIRING SOLICITATION OF
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE PROPOSED
MIDDLE MILE SB ONE FIFTY SIX
ALSO GAVE THE CPC EXPLICIT AND
STRUCTURED STATUTORY DIRECTIONS
FOR ANALYSIS AND PRIORITIZATION
. THEN THE ANALYSIS IS
IDENTIFICATION OF LOCATIONS BUT
ONE ABLE LAST MILE SERVICE THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE NO OPEN ACCESS
MIDDLE MILE WITH SUFFICIENT
CAPACITY AND AFFORDABLE RATE.
THE CDC IS RESPONSIBLE ALSO FOR
IDENTIFYING PARTY LOCATIONS THAT
MEET A NUMBER OF VERY SPECIFIC
OVERLAPPING CRITERIA SUCH AS-
THE CAN BE BUILT EXPEDITIOUSLY.
IT'S WITH NO MIDDLE MILE ACCESS
REGION'S UNDERSERVED BY CURRENT
MIDDLE MOM THAT WORKS REGION'S
WITHOUT SUFFICIENT CAPACITY
LOCATIONS THAT ENABLE LAST MILE
CONNECTIONS TO RESIDENTS OF
UNDER SERVED AT TWENTY FIVE
THREE AND ENTITIES THAT LACK
SUFFICIENT HIGH BANDWIDTH
CONNECTIONS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS SCHOOLS OR LIBRARIES.
BROWN'S IN TROUBLE. SO IN ORDER
TO COLLECT AND ANALYZE THE DATA
THE CDC COMPILED DATASETS FROM
MULTIPLE AND PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
DATA SOURCES SOME OF THESE
INCLUDE STATE HIGHWAY NETWORK
MAPS FROM CALTRANS MIDDLE MY
LOCATIONS CHARACTERISTICS OF
OPEN ACCESS DATA STATUS FROM
DATA REQUESTS FROM APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY CALIBER CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST MIDDLE MILE AND LAST
MILE INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
SUBMITTED TO THE PC MARKET
CONFIDENTIAL. A DATABASE OF
LOCATIONS OF STRUCTURES AND LAND
USE CATEGORIES FROM ONE OF THE
LEADING US BROADBAND MODELING
FIRMS AT THE REQUEST OF ALL THE
CALIFORNIA INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS FOR STATEWIDE
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT AND
ADOPTION DAY THAT ASPECTS OF
WHICH WERE SUBMITTED TO THE TPC
MARKETS CONFIDENTIAL. APPROVED
AND PENDING FEDERAL STATE AND
FEDERAL AND STATE GRANTS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND MIDDLE MILE AND
LAST MILE AWARDS. NATION LEADING
TWICE YEARLY GROUND TROOPS AND
MODELED FEHLER WIRELESS COVERAGE
TO OUR CALVET BE PROGRAM.
DATABASES FOR TRIBAL LANDS AN
ANCHOR INSTITUTION AND OTHER
SENSITIVE DATA INCLUDING
BOUNDARIES PUBLIC USE MICRODATA
THAT THE FEDERAL. TO USE ALL
THESE DATASETS FOR ANALYSIS OVER
THE ENTIRE STATE HIGHWAY NETWORK
WHICH INCLUDES THE APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY ONE HUNDRED MILES OF THE
INITIAL PROPOSED MIDDLE MILE
LOCATION. THANK SLIDE PLEASE.
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO FINISH MY
PRESENTATION WITH THE VISUAL
TIMELINE WHICH SHOWS THE STEPS
THAT YOU CAN SEE A TAKEN FROM
WHEN SB ONE FIFTY SIX PATH TO
TODAY ON THE- MILE. SO THAT THE
FAR LEFT TO SEE BETWEEN AUGUST
AND OCTOBR LAST YEAR WE FOCUSED
ON THE PUBLIC COMMENT PROCESS
THROUGH THE BROADBAND PRECEDING
. THE FACT THAT SB WANTED TO SIX
GAVE US NINETY DAYS FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND GET YOU BACK GOAL.
IN OCTOBER NOVEMBER WE COLLECTED
AND ANALYZED INFORMATION
RECEIVED FROM DATA REQUESTS TO
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK PROVIDERS
AND END OF EMBER THE TPC
CONCURRED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY ON THE EIGHTEEN
INITIAL MIDDLE MILE PROJECT
LOCATION AND RELEASED SUPPORTING
ANALYSIS. IN DECEMBER AND
JANUARY THE CPUC IN COORDINATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY RELEASED ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS MAPS AND DATA INCLUDING
THE PUBLIC COMMENT MAP WHICH I
JUST SHOWED. AND LOCATIONS
WITHOUT BROADBAND ACCESS TO
TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS PER SECOND
DOWN AND THREE MEGABITS PER
SECOND UP. AND CALTRANS SCHEDULE
PROJECT. THANK YOU TO THE RIGHT
TO THE RED DOT OF THE CPC IS
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY ON THE
REMAINING ANALYSIS AND
COORDINATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY ANTICIPATES ITS
RELIEF TO COMMUTER FEBRUARY LIKE
PRIMARY LATER THIS MONTH OR IN
MARCH. WE HELP TO RELEASE THE
DATE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE-
HOWEVER THE PC MUST ALSO ADDRESS
THE REQUEST FOR CONFIDENTIALITY
WE RECEIVED FROM OUR INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS. IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THEIR STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS AND JOURNAL ORDER
SIXTY SIXTY. BEING FOR THE C. P.
HOW WILL BE UP TO THE PROJECT
LOCATE FROM TO TIME AS IN IN SB
ONE FIFTIES. THANK YOU AGAIN
CHAIRWOMAN CORK SILVA AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I LOOK FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AFTER THE COMPLETION
OF THE PRESENTATION. HEY WE HAVE
TO M. MORE- SPEAKERS AND THEN I
KNOW THAT- SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE ITCHING FOR QUESTIONS SO
WE'LL GET TO THOSE QUESTIONS-
NEXT WE WILL HAVE JANICE. BENTON. RIGHT. JERRY IF I MAY JUMP IN
WHERE WE ACTUALLY- WHICH THE
FLOW THAT THE PRESENTATION A
LITTLE BIT TO BE NATURALLY FIT
INTO THE FACE OF THE PROJECT SO
IF I COULD CAUGHT UP- MR AND
FROM MY CODE AND STATE. YES YEAH
YEAH. GOOD MORNING CARE QUICK
SILVA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TONY NORTON
I'M THE PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER GOLDEN STATE
THAT. THE SHAPE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TO YOU TODAY. I HAVE
A LONG BACKGROUND IN DEVELOPING
NETWORKS OF VARIOUS TIMES OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES AND I'M
REALLY PLEASED AND HONORED TO BE
INVOLVED IN AND CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS LITTLE WHILE PROGRAM THAT
WILL PLAY SUCH AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN SERVING UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. GOLDEN
STATE WAS SELECTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
AS A THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
OF THE STATE'S MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND MISSION OF IN
ACCORDANCE WITH SB ONE FIFTY SIX
- AND WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO BE
IN THAT ROLE OF GOLDEN STATE
THAT WAS CREATED ON OCT OUR
PARTY I SHOULD SAY NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE TO FORGOT TO MENTION THAT
THERE WE GO IT'S START OF YOUR
P. JUMPED AHEAD ON THE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE GO BACK. ON THE
SLIDES. AND THEN THE NEXT ONE
PLEASE SORRY ABOUT THE CONFUSION. GOLDEN STATE THAT WAS CREATED
IN AUGUST OF LAST YEAR AS A NON
PROFIT LIMITED LIABILITY
CORPORATION UNDER SCENIC THE
CORPORATION FOR EDUCATIONAL
NETWORK INITIATIVES IN
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU MAY KNOW
SCENIC IS WHEN OPERATING THE
CALIFORNIA RESTRICTION EDUCATION
NETWORK FOR NEARLY TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED
SYSTEM THE CAL STATE SYSTEM AND
PRIVATE RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES.
ARE IN THE STATE CAME TOGETHER
TO FORM THEIR OWN NETWORK AS A
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION DEDICATED
STATEWIDE GATEWAY TO THE
INTERNET. OVER TIME SCENIC IS
OUT OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SCHOOLS PUBLIC LIBRARIES ANOTHER
ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS TO ITS
MEMBER BASE. IT IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING A CARRIER
CLASS CORE BACKBONE NETWORK THAT
CONSISTS OF OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND
MILES OF FIBER TODAY AND KEEPS
CALIFORNIA ON THE CUTTING EDGE
OF RESEARCH EDUCATION. THE
SCENIC BACKBONE INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL BE LEVERAGED TO JUMPSTART
THE SINGLE MILE NETWORK THAT
WE'RE DEVELOPING HERE- AND IT IS
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
THE IMPORTANT MISSIONS OF RESCUE
ONE THIRTY SIX. CERTAINLY SHE
HAS OVER NINETY EXISTING DURING
THE GRIEVANCE FOR TRAFFIC
EXCHANGE WITH BOTH A RESURGENT
WORKS INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
LARGE COMMERCIAL NETWORKS SUCH
AS APPLE AMAZON MICROSOFT GOOGLE
AND MORE. AS WITH ALL OF THE
COMMERCIAL NETWORKS. EXPORTING
AS WITH ALL OF THE LARGEST
NETWORKS AND CONSUMERS OF BIG
DATA SCENE OCCURS AMONG THOSE
ENGAGING IN SETTLEMENT FREE
PEERING AGREEMENTS WHERE THEIR
COSTS ARE LIMITED TO THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH MEETING AND
EXCHANGING TRAFFIC WITH OTHER
NETWORKS. ARRANGEMENT ALLOWS FOR
NETWORKS TO EXCHANGE TRAFFIC
DIRECTLY WITH ONE ANOTHER AND IS
A FOUNDATIONAL PRINCIPLE OF THE
GLOBAL INTERNET ARCHITECTURE.
OFFICIALLY GOLDEN STATE NETWORK-
COMMENCED OPERATIONS AS WELL
WITH THE STATE I SHOULD SAY AS
OF SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE OTHER PARTNERS INVOLVED
PURSUANT TO THE STATURE AND FROM
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM TODAY IN
THIS PRESENTATION. IF YOU GO TO
THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. AS
MENTIONED IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT INITIAL SET OF
EIGHTEEN PROJECT LOCATIONS WERE
ANNOUNCED AND GOLDEN STATE
NOTICE APPROACH YOUR NATURAL.
APPROVED LOCATIONS WITH AN EYE
TOWARDS DEVELOPING THE OVERALL
SYSTEM DESIGN INCLUDING RING
ARCHITECTURES TO SUPPORT NETWORK
RESILIENCY AND AVOID AVOID THE
CREATION OF STRANDED NETWORK
ACCESS ASSETS THAT DON'T CREATE
ANY FACT. ONE COULD THINK ABOUT
SIGNING THE MIDDLE MILE AS
RELATED TO PART. ON ONE SIDE
IT'S ABOUT CREATING AN
INTERCONNECTION FROM THE LAST
MILE TO THE LISLE AND ON THE
SECOND PART CREATING A
CONNECTION FROM THE MIDDLE WHILE
TO THE GLOBAL CORE OF THE
INTERNET. TO SUPPORT RESILIENT
DESIGN. IT'S ABOUT A COMBINATION
OF BUILDING NEW OPTICAL FIBER
AND LEVERAGING EXISTING FIBER-
THROUGH DARK FIBER I HER UNITS
WHICH ARE INDEFEASIBLE RIGHTS OF
USE BY THE WAY THERE'S A-
TYPOGRAPHICAL ERROR ON THIS
SLIDE- IT SHOULD SAY
INDEFEASIBLE RIGHTS OF USE. AS
PART OF THIS WORK WE'VE ENGAGED
WITH MANY COMMERCIAL PROVIDERS
OF BOTH LAST MILE AND DOUBLE
MILE. TRIBAL NATIONS. OF READY
OF METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AS WELL AS CALTRANS AND- IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE
WORKING WITH POTENTIAL LAST MILE
PROVIDERS. THE CUSTOMERS IF YOU
WILL OF THE MIDDLE MILE TO
ENSURE THAT SERVICES REACH THE
END USERS WITHIN THEIR NETWORKS.
THOSE END USERS OF THE HOMES
BUSINESSES TRIBAL NATIONS EVEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WE CAN
ACHIEVE. OF THE MISSION AND
VISION OF THE STATE EFFORT BY
SERVING LAST MILE PROVIDERS WITH
COST EFFECTIVE. HIGH QUALITY
SERVICES ON THE MIDDLE MILE AND
ENABLING ACCESS TO THE MIDDLE
MILE FO THEM BY MEANS OF A
VARIETY OF ACCESS POINTS TO BE
LOCATED. IN A COMBINATION OF
DISTRIBUTED REGIONAL EXCHANGE
POINTS AS WELL CALLING. THE WILL
EXTEND OUT INTO THE SERVICE
RETURNS AS WELL AS OTHER- OF
DISTRIBUTED NETWORK DROPPED AT
LOCATIONS YOU'RE CONNECT
LOCATIONS FOR THE LAST MILE IF
YOU WILL. WITH ACCESS HOLDS UP
AS WELL AS RAPID CAPABILITIES
AND FIBER REACTIVE TO CATION
HUTCH THAT WE LOCATED ON THE
NETWORK AND POTENTIALLY EVEN AT
EXISTING SCENIC POINTS OF
PRESENCE OF WHICH THERE ARE.
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. OUR NEXT FLIGHT. MANY
OF THE TASKS AND OBJECTIVES OF
THE NATIONAL EIGHTEEN PROJECT
MENTIONED ARE BEING EXPANDED AND
LEVERAGE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE REST OF THE STATEWIDE MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK I FORGOT TO MENTION
THE LAST FLIGHT BY THE WAY- BUT
THIS ALSO INCLUDES OF COURSE
ACCOUNTING FOR UP CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICE FUND PROJECTS
TO IMPROVE COORDINATION WITH
EXISTING LAST MILE EFFORTS
ALREADY UNDERWAY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. TO ALLOW FOR THE STATE
WIDE OPEN ACCESS NETWORK TO
PROVIDE NECESSARY SERVICES
EXPEDITIOUSLY EXPEDITIOUSLY TO
THE GLOBAL INTERNET WE NEED TO
CREATE THE NECESSARY
INTERCONNECTIONS FOR THOSE LAST
MILE PROVIDERS WHO ARE EMBEDDED
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND
THIS IS PART OF THE OVERALL
DEVELOPMENT WORK FOR POTENTIAL
SERVICE ARE FRIENDS- WITHIN THE
STATE WIDE NETWORK THAT WE CAN
OFFER AND THAT'S CONTEMPLATED BY
THE STATUTE OF COURSE. FINALLY
WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT. THAT'S
THE STATE WIDE NETWORK MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK INTERCONNECT AND
EXCHANGE TRAFFIC THROUGH
AGREEMENTS WITH ALL OF THE MAJOR
NETWORKS THAT COMPRISE THE REST
OF THE GLOBAL INTERNET. AND WE
ARE WORKING THROUGH AND WILL BE
CONNECTING THROUGH THE
EXTENSIVE. CURRENT TRAFFIC
EXCHANGE AGREEMENTS THAT SCENIC
ALREADY HAS FOR THIS PURPOSE.
ABOVE ALL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO. POINT OUT THAT TRUE
PARTNERING BETWEEN CT CALTRANS
THE CPUC AND GOLDEN STATE NOT
THE THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR IS
WHAT WILL ACHIEVE THE IMPORTANT
GOALS OF SB ONE FIFTY SIX TO
SERVE THE UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WITH
HIGH QUALITY BROADBAND SERVICES
AND DO SO AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
POSSIBLE. I'VE SAID A LOT HERE
SO I'M GOING TO STOP BUT PLEASE
DON'T ASK HAS OKAY TO REACH OUT
TO ME- DURING THE QUESTION
ANSWER OR FOLLOWING UP
THEREAFTER- IN A PRIVATE
DISCUSSION. THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU OUR LAST SPEAKER IS
JANICE BENTON AND IF WE COULD
JUST GO A LITTLE MORE SWIFTLY AS
I KNOW WE- WANT TO MAKE SURE
OUR- MEMBERS HERE CAN ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK
YOU KNOW A GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS JANICE
BURTON AND I AM THE CHIEF OF
CALTRANS DIVISION OF DESIGN. AS
MENTIONED WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF TEXT ALLERGY
DEMANDED CONSTRUCTION OF THE
MIDDLE MILE INFRASTRUCTURE ALONG
THE STATE'S HIGHWAYS. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
ENSURE CORKS DON'T LOOK FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
THE LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP. AND COLLABORATION TO
IMPROVE BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY
IN CALIFORNIA- CALTRANS IS PROUD
TO BE PART OF THE ABOUT
BROADBAND INITIATIVE TO DELIVER
RELIABLE HIGH SPEED INTERNET
ACCESS TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. WE'RE EXCITED THAT
THIS INITIATIVE WILL IMPROVE
ACCESS TO BOB'S. PUBLIC SERVICES
THROUGH VIRTUAL WORLD FROM A
TRANSPORTATION STANDPOINT THIS
REDUCES THE NEED TO PHYSICALLY
TRAVEL WHICH CAN HELP ADDRESS
OUR REGIONAL LOOK NO MOBILITY
ISSUES. THIS MAP SHOWS WHERE THE
MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NEEDED
ACCORDING TO OUR PARTNERS AT THE
UC. RESPOND BASED ON IS NOT WORK
OUR COLLEAGUES AT DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ARE NONE LOCATIONS
TRANS WILL BE UP TO SAY WHAT.
WHAT FIVE. HELLO WORLD CARPET
BEGAN WHAT THEY WANT THE MIDDLE
BOB IF THE AT A PROJECT BETTER
THAN I DID Y OUR PARTNERS AT.
THIS IS MY BIRTHDAY MONTH THAN
ONCE BIGELOW THE TERM HAVING A
LITTLE OF A HARD HERE YOU. FOR
ORDER FOR DISTILLATE PURSUANT TO
OUR ONCE POLICY CALTRANS WILL
BROAD TO PROJECT COULD START AS
WELL AS FIVE ROGER EXPECT TO BE
CONTROL WITHIN MINUTES THREE
YEARS. THE REST OF THE NETWORK
BE CAN THROUGH NEWS MIDDLE MILD
PROJECTS. I THINK YOU'RE ONE.
OKAY AFTER OPENING A NEW STORE
EIGHTEEN PROJECT IS TO BEGIN
WORK ON AN OPEN MIDDLE MILE
BROUGHT NETWORK OKAY IS WORKING
CORRECT BROWN IN THE AT FOURTEEN
OF THE LOCATIONS BY CLICKING ON
THIS THING WENT PART OR BY RT
YOU AND THE LITTLE MILD THAN.
FOR TRANSAMERICA'S TO JUST OVER
ONE HUNDRED POTENTIAL PROJECTS
THE BROADBAND INSTALLATION IN
COORDINATION WITH THE PSEG AND
THE FEEDING TUBE. THIS COVER
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED MILES OF THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM. YEAH
THAT'S THE THING BREAKING GROUND
AS SOON AS TWENTY TWENTY THREE
ON SOME OF THESE IN THIS
LOCATION THE TIME WITH PROJECT
DEPENDS ON THE COMPLEXITY OF
EACH BUILDING LOCATION. BY
RECORDED WILL BEGIN BASED OUR
CLASS WITH THE PARKING TECHNO
LIKE THAT ARE LITTLE BY BACK IN
THE TO BE ON BECAUSE. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO HAVE A PROUD QUICKLY
TO ME FUNDING. AS MUCH OF THE
NEWS HEADLINES AND ENTERING INTO
CONTRACTS THE END TWENTY TWO
FOUR AND EXPENSE BUT RIGHT. SIX
DEMOCRATIC POTENTIAL WILL THAT
ARE MORE TO HAVE TELE WITH THE
BARBARA PLANNERS FOR MAKING AND
WORKING A THE YOU TO THANK WORK
AT THE LOCAL WHETHER PARTNER TO
MAKE SOMETHING. A MAJOR
INITIATIVE LIKE SB ONE. THANKS
TO REACH WHAT THE PLAYGROUND TO
A RECORD WON'T SB ONE SIX AND
EVERYTHING FOR HALF WE HAVE A
LOT MORE COLD AVAILABLE EX BUT I
PROJECT BEGIN. WELL FRANCISCO
MINUTES WORKING WITH OUR PARTNER
AT PERMANENT. AND THE PUBLIC.
COMMISSION AS WE LOOK FOR.
TOGETHER TO HIGH SPEED RELIABLE
INTERNET ACCESS. THE COCKTAIL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I LOOK
FORWARD A QUESTION OF THE
MEETING. BUT FIRST OF. THE MARK
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT'S NOT.
SICKENING SPEAK. HARPER GET-
THANK YOU ARE HELLO THIS BUTTON
ON A LITTLE LESS PLEASE. AFTER
THE- SO IN TURN OF- KIND OF
WHERE WE'RE WE'RE HEADED NOW I'M
SURE WE GET YOUR NAME. I'M THIS
IS MARK MONROE AGAIN WITH
HOUSING OR OKAY THANK YOU. THE
BILL. OKAY YEAH ONE OF PEOPLE A
HEADS UP IN TERMS OF WHAT WE CAN
TO HERE- IN THAT NEAR FUTURE.
BOMB CITY TEENS MOVING FOR WITH
A COMPETITIVE APPROACH- IN THE
COMING WEEKS. APPROXIMATELY%
THREE THOUSAND BY OF THE FIBER-
THE WE WOULDN'T- TO KIND OF GET
OF THE LINE- AS WE MOVE OF THIS
. IN ITS OTHER STATES THAT WE
START TWO X. THEIR- THEIR- WELL
BE PROVIDING REFER. ON MAR FIRST
- THAT IS REQUIRED BY. ONE FIFTY
SO SUPPOSED TO EXPLAIN SOME THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE- WILL
BE- MAYBE NOT THAT SAYS. IN FOR.
RECORD OF THE- REGARDING THAT
SEQUEL OF- IN IN- WORKING- WITH
THAT THEY DON'T STATE NOW. I
WILL BE FINE. DESIGN NET. AND
DEADLINE THAT SIGNED THE NETWORK
BY IT IN JULY AND THE YEAR-
THEN- THEY'RE GONNA YELL BUT THE
- AT ADDING FIBER- UP TO A
FIFTY. THAN IT DOES. EXIST
TRAFFIC PROJECTS WHICH NOW AND-
AND MENTAL CHANGES ASSESS
ANOTHER- EIGHTY OR MORE. FROM
WERE BUT WE COULD AT FIVE OR TO
THE FOOD TO THEM AS WELL. I WITH
THE THAT FRAME OF THAT OF JUST
TWENTY. TWENTY SIX THE FEDERAL
DEADLINE- SO WE ANTICIPATE
SEEING CONSTRUCTIONIST. AS NEXT
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY THREE- ENTIRE
HOUSTON AND LEASE AGREEMENTS
WILL COME TO FOLLOW. AND WITH
THAT- I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR MEMBERS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT- FOR THIS OP IN THE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
PROGRESS. ON THIS IMPORTANT
PROJECT THAT WILL OPEN UP
OPPORTUNITIES TO SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS. AND I LIKE TO
THANK OUR PARTNERS- PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION GOLDEN
STATE NOW AND CALTRANS FOR THEIR
CONSIDERABLE WORK IN MOVING THS
PROJECT FORWARD. AND WITH. THAT
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. I YOU
TO ALL THE SPEAKER. ON OF THE
MEMBERS HERE. THIS WANNA REMIND
PUBLIC THIS HANDOUT WHICH IS
QUITE EXTENSIVE WE'LL BE. ON OUR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE IF YOU WANT
TO SEE THAT AND NOW I'M GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR. THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- AND AS YOU ASK
YOUR QUESTION IF YOU HAVE A
SPECIFIC PERSON YOU'RE GOING TO
ASK THE QUESTION- VICE CHAIR.
YEAH I JUST COUPLE OF AREAS HERE
THAT- I THINK I NEED TO EXPLORE
BASED ON MY PREVIOUS- COMMENTS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE-
CPUC ALREADY AWARDED GRANTS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND PROGRAM FOR BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT PROJECTS. THESE
INCLUDED- MIDDLE MY OFFICE
YLIDES LAST MILE CONNECTIONS. I
NOW UNDERSTAND THAT THESE ARE
PROJECTS ARE BEING REQUIRED TO
GAIN THE CD T. APPROVAL AS WELL
SO HERE IS A NEW INTRODUCTION.
OF REGULATORY DELAY AND
UNCERTAINTY. WHY ARE WE MOVING
IN THIS DIRECTION WHICH ADDS
MORE UNCERTAINTY AND MORE
APPROVALS TO THESE GRANT AWARDS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN APPROVED
. YOU WANT STATURE THAT. THANK
YOU VICE CHAIR THAT THOSE ROBERT
OSBORNE FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION SO AS YOU
INDICATED RECENT CASF
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT- THE
CONTAIN MIDDLE MILE FUNDING
COMPONENTS- WE'RE REQUIRING THAT
GRANT RECIPIENTS MEET WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE MIDDLE
MILECOMPONENTS ARE
COMPLEMENTARY TO THE PROPOSED
MIDDLE MILE BUILD. IT PURPLE
PROCESS SHOULD TAKE PLACE WITHIN
A THREE MONTH TIME PERIOD OR
SOONER- AND- WITH- FROM THAT
GRANT AWARD TIME- BUT THAT MAY
BE EXTENDED BASED ON MUTUAL
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY IN THE GRANT
RECIPIENT- WE'VE ALREADY KICKED
OFF OUR FIRST MEETING WITH ONE
PROVIDER AND WE HAVE TWO MORE
THAT ARE PLANNED. TO GET THAT
PROCESS UNDERWAY IN REALLY THE
INTENT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING INVESTMENT
OF PRECIOUS STATE MONEY. ALL
RIGHT- A COUPLE OF OBSERVATIONS
WITH RESPECT TO THE INITIAL LIST
OF EIGHTEEN. I LOCATION IF YOU
LOOK AT THE LISTING. BUT IT IT
LOOKS AS IF THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT AREAS FOR WHICH
THEIR BRAND BROADBAND SERVICE
ALREADY IN THOSE. AREAS AND IT
LOOKS TO ME- AS IF THE CD T.
APPROVAL PROCESS I THINK THE-
REALLY FAILED TO LOOK AT THE
UNDERSERVED AREAS THAT LACK
TWENTY FIVE THREE SERVICE- AND I
THINK THAT. WHAT I'D LIKE TO ASK
C. T. WHAT ARE CITY T. GOING TO
DO TO ENSURE THAT THAT THAT NEXT
BATCH OF LOCATIONS FOR STATE
MIDDLE MILE DEPLOYMENT. WILL BE
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS LACKING
TWENTY FIVE THREE SERVICES AS
EXPECTED BY THE ENABLING
LEGISLATION. SURE OUR WORK
BETTER AGAINST THE DUTY SO- MARK
WE'RE HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING
YOU YEAH ARE THERE YOU KNOW- DID
YOU PROJECTS WERE AT WERE
SELECTED WITH A KIND OF A THAT
IS A STEP APPROACH TO REALLY I'M
A GUEST BASEDON SOME LIMITED IN
THAT THE INFORMATION THAT THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION OUT
OF THE TIME. A RELATIVE TO WHERE
WE NEEDED THE SYSTEM SO AS WE
MOVE FORWARD- ALC- ON OUR
WEBSITE- THE MATH THE MATH THAT
WAS PROVIDED BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THAT TO
REALLY IDENTIFY WHERE THOSE-
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED AREAS
ARE- THAT NOW THAT WE HAVE THAT
COMPLETE WE HAVE WE WILL BE
BUILDING OUT- AND IN DEVELOPING
THE SYSTEM IN RESPONSE TO THAT
MAP SO. WHERE IS THE EIGHT THE
ORIGINAL EIGHTEEN- WE WANTED TO
LEARN YOU KNOW GET A
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO BUILD HOW WE CONNECT THAT TO
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE- AND
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO REALLY WORK IN
BOTH URBAN AND RURAL AREAS IN
MOUNT AIRY MOUNTAINOUS AREAS IN.
DESERT AREAS SO WE WERE REALLY
OF TRYING TO TRY TO USE THAT THE
MOST OPPORTUNE WEEKEND WITH SB.
ONE FIFTY SIX TO GET STARTED.
START THAT. OF ABOVE THE LAW TO
PUT THIS THING. AND SO ON GOING
FOR- ABSOLUTE YOU KNOW THAT IS
THAT GOAL YOU WANT TO SIX IS TO.
ADDRESS THE NEED AND THE- FOR.
ON SERVER UNDER. AND SO- GOING
FOR PRICE WILL BE. TO WITH THAT. ALL RIGHT- ASSEMBLY RAYOS.
BILL AND THEN ASSEMBLY BONTA
AFTER. IN ONE OF THE- HANDELT OF
MARC BERMAN ROW I THINK YOUR
FIRST PAGE. IT PAGE IS TIED
WORKING TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE SB
ONE FIFTY SIX AND THE EACH OF
THE DEPARTMENTS IS LISTED.
HOLDEN YEAR FILLING YOUR FAST.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF WE
CAN GET SOMETHING THAT IS SET UP
IN A HIERARCHICAL FASHION. WHO
IS ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE IF WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WHO IS THE ONE
PERSON OR THE ONE DEPARTMENT
THAT WE CAN GO TO AND SAY YOU
NEED TO GET EVERYBODY ELSE IN
ORDER AS OPPOSED TO TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT. WHO'S WHO'S IN
CHARGE OF WHAT PART OF IT. CAN
WE- NO WHO IS ULTIMATELY IN
CHARGE. YEAH ABSOLUTELY. IN THE
SHORT ANSWER THAT IS IT'S ME BOB
IT'S NOT THE- THE MIRAMAR
BROADBAND INITIATIVE OFFICE
WITHIN- CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND SO- YOU KNOW THAT
KIND OF IN MY POSITION MY OFFICE
WORK WERE REALLY THAT THE FACE
OF THAT PROJECT IT'S OUR JOB TO
WORK WITH OTHER PARTNERS BUT
I'LL SAY IS THAT- WHAT WAS LAID
OUT THERE WAS- ON SOME LEVEL-
KIND OF BRING YOU SHOW THE FLOW
OF THE PROCESS WHERE. OVERALL CD
KEY IS- IS GUIDING THE PROJECT
ENDED IN THREE FOUR AT THE
COMPLETION OF THE PROJECT AND
THEN YOU CAN KIND OF SEE THERE
ARE WITH THE- THE VARIOUS
PARTNERS ROLES- WITH THE PC
PROVIDING MAPPING- AND THE STATE
NOT PROVIDING THAT- THE
PROVIDING THAT THAT THAT LED. OF
THIS. THAT TO CHECK HEALTH TO
GET AND CAL BILL AT SEEING OF
THE KIND OF LAID OUT WITH THAT
IN. BUT ALSO. YOU KNOW THE-
PARKS WITH OUR OFFICE. IT IF I
MISTER- ON THE FLY AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT FOR THE ANSWER ON THE
SLIDE THAT'S A- WITH THE HEADING
FEDERAL FUNDING RULE. IT'S THAT
THE THREE TWO FIVE BILL. IS
ESTIMATED TO BE ENOUGH BUILD A
SIX THE TO A HEN. MILE SIXTY OF
THE EIGHT THEY'LL MILES THIS.
ACCORDING TO THE ALEJO'S REPORT
THE FIRST EIGHT PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN A- ACCOUNT FOR EIGHT
TO NINE HUNDRED MILES. IT IS MY
INFORMATION CORRECT AND ARE WE
GOING TO BE ON TRACK TO DO OUR
SIX THOUSAND MILES. YES REALLY
HOW THE WAY THAT THE SIX
THOUSAND MILES WAS DETERMINED
WAS- AN INITIAL ESTIMATE BY-
CALTRANS IS LESS BRING IN TERMS
OF WHAT THESE PROJECTS THAT SOME
SMALLER PROJECTS ACOSTA IN THE
PAST. WE AND SO WE NORMALLY ASK
OF THAT THE WAY CALTRANS IN ANY
OF ITS PROJECTS THAT WOULD
DEVELOP ITS COST ESTIMATES- IT
WOULD DO IT KIND OF STARTS WITH
THE A PROJECT INITIATION- A
DOCUMENT. PROCESS YOU KNOW HOW
WE PROJECTS TAKE A LOT LONGER-
BECAUSE THEY'RE A LOT MORE
INVOLVED IN THIS- AND SO. THEY
WERE GOING TO GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS- TO IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE
COSTS WOULD BE AND SO- IT
BECAUSE OF THE ACCELERATED
NATURE OF THIS PROJECT GOT
CALTRANS ACTUALLY DOING THAT AS
PART OF TE PRECONSTRUCTION-
PROCESS AND SO THEY ARE.
CURRENTLY DEVELOPING THESE THESE
EIGHTEEN PROJECTS AND REFINING
THEIR ESTIMATES ABOUT THE COST
WILL. BE SO- DR BROADLEAF. THE
OTHER SICK THOUSAND IS. YOU KNOW
. AGAIN AT THE KIND OF THAT
INITIAL HIGH- DISCUSSION WERE
HOPE THAT THE AS WE MOVE. IF A
BILL TO ACHIEVE. A SAVINGS-
ENERGY FOR YOU KNOW SORT OF
SCALE- AND SOME OF THE OTHER
COMPONENTS WERE LOOKING AT TO BE
ABLE TO MAYBE DRAW DOWN THOSE
COSTS THE BUILDING OR- BUT IT'S
REALLY THAT THAT THE AND- OF US
ONE FIFTY. ONE TO. AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE BUILD OUT A OWNED
SYSTEM AND SO THAT'S REALLY THE
PHONE- BUT- THAT THAT WOULD COME
. A BASED INITIAL- PROBABLY
CLOSER TO FOUR BILLION. THIS SB
ONE SIX- CD T. TWO. TO FILL IN
THE REST OF THE SYSTEM USING THE
AGREEMENT. AND LYFT QUESTION I
MAY I ASK EARLY. AND I AM YOU.
THAT ARE THE PER TO ASK MR ONE.
WHAT IS THE ESTÁ CALL OF THOSE
EIGHT PRODUCT THAT OF ALL BEEN.
APPROVED IN RELATION TO THE.
THREE POINT TWO SIX BILLION. SO
ON A BRITISH- WHAT I CAN DO IS
ON OF THE THAT THE NATIONAL WHEN
WE PUT THE- THIS PROPOSAL LAST
SUMMER- I WANT TO SAY IT'S A- IT
IT WITH BE THE THREE EIGHTY
MILLION RANGE THAT IT'S A VERY
HIGH LEVEL THAT IS VERY
PRELIMINARY AND PART OF AGAIN
THE REASON I WANT TO CARRY OUT
THAT IS THAT CALTRANS IS GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS RIGHT NOW
OF REALLY REFINING THAT NUMBER
THAT. AND THAT'S- I WANNA MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT-
SIMILARLY THAT ASSUMES THAT WE
ARE- BUILDING- ALL EIGHT HUNDRED
YOU KNOW ROUGHLY A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILES- AND- PART OF THE
ASSESSMENT WE'RE DOING IS TO GO
BACK AND SEE WHERE WHERE. WHERE
MIGHT WE LINK UP WITH EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE- YOU KNOW AND SO
THOSE ARE ALL THE PROCESSES THAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH SO. IF WE
WERE TO JUST ASSUME. ON A
STRAIGHT LINE THAT WE'RE HERE
THAT WE'RE BAY THEY WERE
BUILDING ALL EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILES. THEN YOU KNOW ONE
COULD ESTIMATE THE THREE
HUNDRED. SEVENTY FIVE THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR
RANGE. BUT AGAIN THAT'S STILL
BEING THAT. THAT'S BE REFINED BY
CALTRANS. THANK YOU THAT GIVES
US HOPE THAT MANY OF OUR OTHER
AREAS THE ARE GOING BEING. IN
THESE FUTURE PROJECTS IF THIS IS
ONLY THREE HUNDRED MILLION THANK
YOU MISTER MONROE. THANK YOU ON
NEXT ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I IT THIS IS
PROBABLY A QUESTION DIRECTED
TOWARDS MR OSBORNE OR PERHAPS
INSTRUMENT ROSE WELL I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY BECAUSE WE SEEM TO BE
USING AS A PROXY FOR UNDER
SERVED- WHETHER OR NOT AND AT AN
AREA IS URBAN OR NOT- BEING
INTIMATELY FAMILIAR WITH ONE OF
THOSE FIRST EIGHTEEN PROJECTS I
HAVE TO SAY THAT I AM VERY SURE.
THAT THERE IS A LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IN MIDDLE MÀ
INFRASTRUCTURE ALREADY EXISTING
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO- SUPPORT
VISIT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES IN IN MY DISTRICT I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY AGAIN AND
I SEE- MR OSBORNE ON YOUR- ON
THE SLIDE ENTITLED CPUC ROLE
MIDDLE MILE DATA AND ANALYSIS
YOU DO HAVE SOME STATUTORY
MAPPING CRITERIA. AND
PRIORITIZATION AND I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT THE EIGHTEEN
PROJECTS ALREADY INDICATED
ACTUALLY MET THE CRITERIA FOR
NOT HAVING THE CURRENT RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEEDED IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR RECEIPT OF
THESE DOLLARS AND- AND TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THAT MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARC SAID THIS ROBERT ALL
FROM THE PEACE. YOU'RE CORRECT
THERE ARE PARTS AND URBAN
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE UNSERVED
AND UNDER SERVED- WE CALL THEM
SORT OF COURT COLLOQUIALLY DONE
AT HOLES IN THE SENSE THAT
THEY'RE MISSING BROADBAND IN THE
CENTER. SO- YOU ARE CORRECT ON
THAT AND YES- THE EIGHTEEN-
PROJECT LOCATIONS CONSIDER
UNSERVED AND- AS YOU STATED FOR
THE URBAN AREAS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOTTOM FINISHED OKAY MEMBER-
PERFECT BOERNER HORVATH. YEAH
I'M YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS PRESENT FASTER I WOULD LIKE
TO DIG A LITTLE BIT INTO THESE
EIGHTEEN PROJECTS LIKE I SEE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN AS RIVERSIDE SAN
DIEGO LIKE RIVERSIDE SAN DIEGO
IS A GIANT AREA LIKE I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW CAN YOU TELL ME A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROJECT AND
ONE THING I'M CONCERNED ABOUT A
MAYBE I MISSED HEARD BUT WHEN WE
WERE GIVEN THE EXAMPLE OF THE
MIDDLE MILE PROJECT IN NEVADA
COUNTY I BELIEVE SOMEBODY SAID
THAT A SUPERVISOR HAD SUGGESTED.
THIS ROUTE. AND I THINK THAT'S I
MEAN IF THAT'S WHAT IT IS I
SHOULD HAVE CALLED IN AND I
SHOULD REQUEST THE STUFF
OCEANSIDE BECAUSE WE HAVE A
DONUT HOLE IN OCEANSIDE. SO I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT ALL THE PROJECTS THAT WERE
FUNDING. ARE OBJECTIVELY MEETING
THE CRITERIA AND NOT JUST- A
PROJECT THAT SERVES ONE
SUPERVISOR NEVADA COUNTY VERSUS
ACTUALLY SATISFYING. THE
REQUIREMENTS SET OUT THE BILL.
SO MAYBE COULD SOMEBODY COULD GO
THROUGH. EXACTLY HOW THESE
EIGHTEEN WERE CHOSEN. AND MAYBE
LESS OF A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
RIVERSIDE SAN DIEGO BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROJECT IS
AND I HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT IT.
AND THE SECOND QUESTION THAT I
HAVE THAT YOU CAN ANSWER WITH
IT. IS- WHAT METRICS ARE YOU
USING TO SHOW THAT THESE
EIGHTEEN PROJECTS ARE THE BEST
USE OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS. YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE HOT WE HAVE THE
CRITERIA THE FROM THE BILL BUT
YOU MUST AVE THE METRICS OF
SUCCESS TO SAY THIS IS THE BEST
BANG FOR A BUCK RIGHT SO CAN
SOMEBODY GO THROUGH THOSE TWO
THINGS BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED.
THAT YOU KNOW. WHAT THAT MAYBE
WE'RE NOT HAVING THE BEST
OBJECTIVE PROJECTS FOR OUR STATE
THAT ARE SERVING THE MOST AND
SERVE PEOPLE AND CALIFORNIA.
SURE HOLD ON YEAH MARC BERKLEY
CD KAEL JAPAN AND THAT THE
PROBABLY EIGHTEEN WERE CHOSEN WE
REALLY WANTED TO GET- BUT WE
WANTED TO GET A START ON THIS
OVERALL PROJECT AND SO. MAYBE IT
AN IMPORTANT THING TO POINT OUT
IS THAT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A PROJECT THAT THE SIZE IN
THE TIME FRAME THAT WERE UNDER
IN TERMS OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS-
WE NEED TO BE REALLY APPROACHING
A BROADER PROJECT- AS A WHOLE
RIGHT AND SO THAT MEANS WERE IN
THE BUILDING YOU KNOW MULTIPLE
SEGMENTS AT THE SAME TIME- WE'RE
NOT GOING TO- JUST IN ORDER TO
MEET THE TIME FRAME. SO- GIVEN
THAT AS WE APPROACH THE- PROD.
THOSE WERE. AGAIN THE PRIMARILY
ARE THEY WERE BOB. FROM THE STAY
. THAT AS THE- WAS GOING THROUGH
ITS PUBLIC PROCESS- YOU KNOW I'M
NOT CERTAIN. S. B. ONE FIFTY SIX
FOR. THE THEY- DO THAT SUCH
MEASURE UNTIL I. WHERE THE ON
AND UNDER. ARE AND- TO HAVE A-
PROCESS- SO WE GET TO THE PUBLIC
PROCESS THESE. YES THEY ARE OPEN
TO ANY. AND WE YOU KNOW WE YOU
SEE I THINK ALL PARTNERS KERR-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AT ANYBODY
TO REALLY ENGAGE IN THAT PART.
PROCESS THAT WAS GOING ON IN IN
ALL. AND SEPTEMBER- TO REALLY
HELP IN. OUR PC'S PROCESSING
THEY ALSO WORK- WHAT THE-
DIRECTLY TO GET INTO. OF THE
HELPING. NOT UP BUT BUT I DON'T
WANT TO USE. THAT THE EIGHTEEN.
WAS ATTENDED TO IDENTIFY IS
WHERE THE GREATEST NEED IN THE
STATE IS. THESE OTHER THERE- THE
SYSTEM A WHOLE WELL IT IS
INTENDED TO. ADDRESS THAT THE
STATE NEED AS A WHOLE. ARE THESE
IT KRAJ FOR SO. BE THEY WILL
GIVE US SOME CRITICS. IN A
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE AREAS-
THEY'LL GIVE US SOME EXPERIENCE
IN. RURAL AREAS URBAN AREAS AND
TRYING TO CONNECT TO EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SO- AND
AGAIN MOST IMPORTANTLY THEY THAT
THE UC HAD. IN ITS ANALYSIS.
HAVE BEEN ABLE WAS ABLE TO SAY
WITHIN A REASONABLE LEVEL OF
CERTAINTY AT STAFF LEVEL BUT-
THESE PROJECTS THESE SEGMENTS
NEEDED A SOLUTION AND SO. THIS
YEAR WE WILL GO FORWARD WITH.
THAT- GOING- THE- THE MET. WILL
BE VERY MUCH IN YOU GO TO A
WEBSITE KIND OF SEE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES- MAPPED- KIND OF DATA
FOR YOU COULD IDENTIFY. AND
COMMUNITIES AND- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT'S REALLY WE'RE TARGET
SO THAT'S THE- OF THIS MILE. AND
CERTAINLY ANY. BEADS GOING
FORWARD- ARE GOING TO BE TO.
ALLOW THE COLOR THAT INTO SAYS.
AND THAT'S REALLY- YOU KNOW THE
VALUE OF THE SYSTEM IS THAT IT
WHOLE NOW. IT'S SAYS AND THAT IT
ALL PLUGS INTO OF THE- AND GETS
EVERY TOGETHER. TO HAVE- THE
INTERNET. MHM AND THE THING TONG
LIKE TO ASK THE RAW- OFFERING C.
P. COULD ALL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
. TO WHAT- AT THE END MISTER
ROTH MAY- I JUST WANT AND FOR
THE- THAT. OF AT PROBABLY HAVE
HER. EARLIER THAT EVENING EIGHT.
IT'S S. OF THE INDIAN THAI
CALIFORNIA. AND THE ENTIRE.
NETWORK IT'S THE THAT THE
CURRENTLY IN. ON THE WEB. BASED
ON THE GOOD WORK FROM THE WITH
STIFF HAVE DONE. IN ROBBING A
FEW. PROVIDE BIT MORE CONTACTS
ON INITIAL. WHAT CRITERIA THAT
WITH APPLY AND HOW DOES THAT
CARE OVER- TO- DEVELOP THE STATE
. MAP. SURE THANK YOU DIRECTOR
TALKING THE IS ROBERT OUT FROM
THE PC. SO THE INITIAL PROJECT
LOOK STORAGE. TO SUPPORT
MULTIPLE OBJECT. FIRST WITH THE
TEST APPROACHES FOR THE MIDDLE
THAT WERE. AS MARK INDICATED
EARLIER. SHE ALSO TO X. PROD AN
AIR IN THE STATE THERE WERE. BY
OPEN AT MODEL MILE IN FOR. OPEN
ACCESS TO KEY WERE HERE BE WE'RE
- OF. MIDDLE MILE THAT IS EXTRA
. ON A NON DISCRIMINATORY. FOR A
LAUGH MONTH PRICE- THIRD
LEVERAGE A FISH. AND WITH
PENDING. CONSTRUCTION PROJECT IN
THE FOR TO COORDINATE WITH
PENDING CAL. MAN SERVICES FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE LAST MILE GRANTS
THAT INCLUDE MIDDLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO THE PROJECTS
ARE GROUPED INTO ONE OR MORE OF
THE FOLLOWING THREE GROUP THINKS
THERE IS A GROUP ONE WHICH
FOCUSED ON. SERVICE TO UNSERVED
AREAS THAT CAN BE BUILT
EXPEDITIOUSLY ARE TIED TO SEE PC
OR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROJECTS.
FOR LAST MILE GROUP TWO WAS
FOCUSED ON SERVICE TO UNSERVED
AREAS THAT CAN BE BUILT
EXPEDITIOUSLY. IN COORDINATION
WITH CALTRANS AND GROUP THREE
LET'S FOCUS ON SERVICE TO
UNSERVED AREAS THAT AVE A GREAT
NEED OR OPPORTUNITY AREAS WHICH
ARE DEMONSTRATED BY PUBLIC
COMMENT. I THINK THOUGH TO GET
BACK TO THE ORIGINAL QUESTION-
WITH REGARD TO PUBLIC COMMENT
THE PUBLIC COMMENT MAP IS A
PUBLIC COMMENT MAP IT IS NOT
THAT A DECISION ON FINAL. BUILD
LOCATION AND THE DETERMINATION
OF WHERE TO FINALLY BUILD HAVE
TO BE TIED TO UNSERVED LOCATIONS
SO IT'S NOT A POPULARITY
CONTEST. AND SECONDLY IF YOU DO
HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENT TO
PROVIDE WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENTS STILL ON FRIDAY. IN
FORMAL PUBLIC COMMENT. SO WHEN
MICHAEL WAS A THE SPECIFICALLY
AROUND RIVERSIDE DIEGO. CAN
SOMEBODY INTO A LITTLE OF DETAIL
ABOUT THE PROJECT. WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THAT PROJECT WHEN IS IT
CAN BE DONE HOW MANY PEOPLE IS
THAT. I'M I'M HOW MANY PEOPLE DO
WE THINK THAT IT'S GONNA SERVE.
YOU KNOW IT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO HAVE METRICS AROUND IT. SO
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
STRETCH ACROSS THIS MANY DOLLARS
BUT IT'S GOING TO CONNECT WITH
MANY. ARM UNDER OR UNSERVED
PEOPLE ARE HOUSEHOLDS HOWEVER
YOU WANNA ARE YOU ALSO TALKED
ABOUT- COMMUNITY USES. WHAT
METRICS ARE YOU DO YOU HAVE IN
PLACE. TO ENSURE NOT ONLY CAN
YOU DO IT FAST AND YOU HAVE
SYNERGIES WITH OTHER EXISTING
PROJECTS. BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE
GETTING THE MOST BANG FOR THE
BUCK AND CALIFORNIA FOR THESE
PROJECTS. WHAT METRICS YOU HAVE
IN PLACE NOW. THAT SHOW IS THAT
THE IS THE BEST USE OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS NOW. I'M GOING TO DEFER
TO MARK ON THAT QUESTION. YEAH
SO- INFIRM SERVICES IMPORTER
MEMBER THAT MIDDLE MILE NO
AMOUNT OF ITSELF DOESN'T- IT
DOESN'T CONNECT TO OUR HOUSES
RIGHT I UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE MY LAST
MY BUT YOU HAVE SOME PLAN ABOUT
THE LAST MILE USAGE THAT'S GOING
TO BE THAT CRAP. RIGHT AND SO WE
KNOW ONCE IN AWHILE IS BUILT
WILL BE IT WILL HAVE- YOU KNOW
LAST MILE THAT CAN CONNECT TO
IT- IN TERMS OF. THE THIS
PROJECT BEING AHEAD OF OTHERS- I
YOU KNOW I DON'T WANT TO SAY
THAT IT WAS THE- WE SAY THAT THE
BOOK ABOUT. THE BIGGEST BANG FOR
THE BUCK IT WAS IT IS THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR THE BUCK FROM
THE STANDPOINT THAT WE CAN GET
IT STARTED NOW. AND WE HAVE A
CALTRANS YOU KNOW WORKING OR
WORKING WITH CALTRANS TO
STREAMLINE THEIR PROCESSES- TO.
TO DEVELOP THE PROJECT I'M
LOOKING FOR YOU KNOW
ALTERNATIVES TO. OPPORTUNITY
CONNECT WITH THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH- GOLDEN
STATE NOT- BUT I DON'T WANT IT
YOU KNOW THAT THE IDEA OF THE
INITIAL EIGHTEEN WASN'T TO SAY
THESE WORDS. THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY. THAT THE STATE WILL
COME UP WITH. THAT HAD THAT AT
THAT POINT THAT ASSESSMENT
HADN'T REALLY BEEN DONE SO FAR-
WASN'T COMPLETED UNTIL THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION IS
CONTINUING. JERRY OKAY LET'S
CONTINUE TO DO THEIR ANALYSIS
AND- AND THIS WAS AN AREA WERE.
NEED WAS IDENTIFIED AND THAT'S
REALLY WHY IT IT AND. THE OTHER
PROJECTS WERE SELECTED. I WOULD
. SUGGEST THAT WE CREATE. GOING
FORWARD. I UNDERSTAND THESE WERE
ONES THAT CAN BE DONE NOW NEVER
SYNERGIES. BUT GOING FORWARD FOR
THE REST OF THE MONEY. I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE. WHAT OUR METRICS OF
SUCCESS WHY ARE WE USING IT HERE
AND NOT THERE BECAUSE- THERE'S
PROBABLY MORE THAT WE NEED TO
DO. THAT BEYOND THE NUMBER OF
DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE A SIGN AND
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK. AND SAY.
THIS IS THE BEST BANG FOR A
BUCK. WE ARE INVESTING. OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS WISELY. RIGHT
AS I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU COME
UP WITH METRICS SO THAT THE NEXT
TIME WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
THERE'S VERY CLEAR METRICS ON
EACH OF THE PROJECTS THAT WE CAN
SAY. IS THE BEST BANG FOR A BUCK
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
AND STILL IF SOMEBODY CAN GOING
TO REPRESENT SAN DIEGO. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I WANT TO
AS CHAIR. TO THANK ALL OF THE-
SPEAKERS THAT WE HAVE TODAY AS
WE CAN SEE THERE ARE A LOT. OF
PLAYERS IN THIS. INITIATIVE TO
BRING BROADBAND TO ALL IN
CALIFORNIA I'LL JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS AND THEN WE'LL OPEN IT
UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS- I WOULD
SAY I THINK SOME OF THE- CONCERN
YOU'RE HEARING FROM SOME OF THE
MEMBERS. IS IN MANY WAYS.
THEY'RE HEARING SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE HEARD. AS
A MYSELF IN A PARTICIPANT ON THE
MIDDLE MILE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WHICH IS SOME OF THE SAME- AREAS
OF HOW WERE THE EIGHTEEN
PROJECTS- DECIDED UPON. AS WAS
MENTIONED WHAT IS THE CRITERIA
BUT I THINK THE CONCERN IS WHEN
WE LOOK OUT TO TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. WILL WE IN FACT BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE. AND PROVIDE BROADBAND
ACCESS TO ALL AND SOME OF US WHO
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN PROJECTS
WHETHER THEY BE IN
TRANSPORTATION OR OTHER SYSTEMS
I THINK SME OF THE FEAR IS WILL
WE RUN OUT OF MONEY WELL WE NOT
USE IT IN A TIMELY WAY. AND THEN
IN THE END WHEN WE STILL HAVE
AREAS THAT ARE UNDERSERVED THAT
WE DID NOT GET TO SO THOSE ARE
JUST SOME OF THE OVERALL-
COMMENTS THAT I THINK- ARE BEING
EXPRESSED TODAY. WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS A YOUR FIRST REPORT
COMING MARCH FIRST- I THINK
THERE THERE WILL BE QUITE A BIT
OF INTEREST IN THAT AND WE WILL
CONTINUE AS A COMMITTEE. TO NOT
ONLY ON ENGAGE BUT MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MEMBERS TO BE UPDATED- WE WILL
ALSO BE HEARING- DOING A SECOND
INFORMATIONAL HEARING EARLY
APRIL ON THE LAST MILE SO AGAIN
WE WANT TO THANK YOU WE KNOW
THAT TED THIS IS NOT AN EASY
LIFT LIFTING ANY MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THROUGH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IS INDEED A HEFTY
LEFT WE JUST ALL WANT TO. AS MY
CO CHAIR SAY WERE IN A SAID
WE'RE IN A GOLDEN MOMENT AND WE
WANT TO SEE THAT ACTUALLY COME
TO FRUITION BUT AGAIN THANK YOU
TO ALL I THINK WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP TO- PUBLIC. M. MEMBERS AND. YET WE
MENTIONED THE PHONE NUMBER AT
THE VERY BEGINNING I WILL GIVE
IT ONE MORE TIME- IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN AND FOR THIS HEARING
THE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR.
THREE SEVEN AND WE WELCOME
YOU'LL WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
THAT ATTENDED TODAY I FOUND OUT
A LOT OF ROBUST INFORMATION. TO
THE PUBLIC. BUT WE HAVE ONE IN
PERSON. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO
WITH A CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
ONE OF THE LARGEST INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THIS HEARING THIS IS A
VERY GREAT DISCUSSION AND I
THINK WE'RE OFF TO A GREAT
START. I WANTTO DIAL BACK JUST
A LITTLE BIT FOR WHAT IS YOUR
CHALLENGE HERE BECAUSE A YEAR A
LOT ABOUT THE LAST OF THE MIDDLE
MILE IN THE UNSERVED SO-
CALIFORNIA HAS THIRTEEN MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS WE HAVE THIRTY
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS AND MR
PATERSON ALLUDED TO A FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE UNSERVED THESE ARE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. THAT IS
WHAT YOU'RE AFTER THAT IS WHAT
YOU WANT TO FOCUS ON HALF OF
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS ARE IN THE ROOM
AND HALF OF THOSE ARE URBAN BUT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROBLEMS ARE IN THE RURAL AREA
YOU HAVE LACK OF DENSITY AND
HOME SPREAD OUT FOR PARTNERS
THERE'S VERY LITTLE CONNECTIVITY
OUT THERE. IN AN URBAN SEARCH
AND CENTER YOU HAVE POCKETS IT'S
A DIFFERENT TYPE OF CHALLENGE
IT'S ONE THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY REQUIRE MIDDLE MILE
IT REQUIRES BUILDING UP THAT
LAST MILE TO THESE UNSERVED
POCKETS SO YOU CAN GO WITH A
VERY COSTLY APPROACH OF
DUPLICATING MIDDLE MILE AND
URBAN AREA. BUT REALLY THE
CHALLENGES IS GETTING TO THAT
LAST MILE HOUSEHOLD SO SOME OF
THESE POCKETS OR LIKE PUBLIC
HOUSING. IT WAS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DECISION NOT TO
BUILD BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY IN
THOSE UNITS WHEN THEY WERE BUILT
SO SOMETHING MIGHT LOOK AT IN
THE FUTURE TO REQUIRE PUBLIC
HOUSING TO ENSURE THAT WHEN THE
BILL PUBLIC HOUSE AND THEY HAVE
IT SOME OF THEM MAY BE- TRAILER
PARKS- MOBILE HOME PARKS SO THAT
THE PROPERTY OWNER DO NOT A LOT
SO YOU HAVE SOME PROPERTY RIGHTS
ISSUES THAT YOU NEED TO BE
CHARGED WITH. FIRST CONNECTIVITY
OUT IN THE STREET SO YOUR CHILD
FROM URBAN RURAL IS GONNA BE
DIFFERENT FOR UNSERVED OF MORE
IMPORTANTLY IN THE URBAN AREAS
WHEN I THINK A LOT OF
LEGISLATORS STOP THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE CONNECTIVITY AND OUR
HELP LOS ANGELES AREA. IT WAS
NOT THAT THERE WASN'T A SERVICER
BUT THERE WAS NO PORTABILITY
ISSUE OR THE HOUSE OF DIDN'T
ADOPT SO THERE'S. ONE POINT NINE
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS THAT COULD
NOT BROADBAND. BUT DID SOLEIL.
CC SPONSOR TWO PIECES ALLEGE. TO
GET. A K. TWELVE STUDENTS
CONNECTED TO GET PUBLIC HOUSING
AND CONNECTED. UNFORTUNATELY
RUSTIC SESIL BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO. YOU KNOW ADDRESSING THOSE
ISSUES IN THE FUTURE. SO THAT'S
YOUR CHALLENGE HOW TO GET TO
THESE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS. SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IS NOT A LOT OF MONEY SO
YOU NEED TO USE IT WISELY. WE
WOULD STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT YOU
FOCUS ON THOSE HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE IN
THREE. SO THAT SHOULD BE YOUR
TARGET- AND LASTLY I WANT TO
MENTION ABOUT THE EIGHTEEN
DIFFERENT PILOT PROJECTS. MIDDLE
MILE PROJECTS ARE NOT UNIQUE TO
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL-
I THINK IN THE FUTURE. THE
COMMITTEE MAY WANT TO DRILL DOWN
ON SOME OF THOSE PROJECTS. THERE
WAS THE THREE NINETY FIVE
DIGITAL THREE NINETY FIVE THAT
GOES FROM BARSTOW TO RENO IT
COST A BILLION DOLLARS. IN YOU
MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT HOW WE'RE
HOUSEHOLDS CONNECTED IN THOSE
PROJECTS AND IN THAT PROJECT. SO
IT GOES THROUGH FIVE
RESERVATIONS I'VE HEARD THAT-
THE HEAD OFFICE WILL HAVE
CONNECTIVITY BUT THE ACTUAL
HOUSEHOLDS ON THOSE RESERVATIONS
DO NOT. SO I WOULD GO DOWN ON
THAT PROJECT FOR THE TWO NINETY
NINE DIGITAL TO NINE NINE
PROJECT THAT GOES FROM- EUREKA
OVER TO REDDING COTTON WOOD. AND
THAT WAS A FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT. IT WAS VERY
EXPENSIVE THE PROPONENT WANTED
TO DOUBLE THAT SO HE SAID THAT
WAS NOT ENOUGH SO THAT PROJECT
FAILED. SO WE HAVE PROJECTS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA YOU DON'T NEED TO
GO YOU DON'T NEED TO DO PILOTS
SO MUCH YOU NEED TO GO DRILL
DOWN AND LEARN AND TAKE THE
LEARNING LESSONS FROM THOSE
PROJECTS. AND I WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN IT ONE LAST SHOT OUT TO A
CALTRANS. SO CALTRANS HAS BEEN A
GREAT PARTNER IN THE PAST SO I
THINK MR WHICH NOT HERE BUT
UNDER THE DIRECTION MISTER
WOULD. YES ENCOURAGE CALTRANS TO
WORK WITH IS PIECE AND WE HAVE
MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS IN THAT
AREA. SO WITH THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND- AGAIN IN OUR
PANDEMIC WORLD I WAS JUST
SURPRISED TO SEE SOMEBODY IN
PERSON HERE SO. THANK YOU FOR
COMING NEXT. HI MY NAME LATER ON
THE POLLING HIRING. I PURCHASED
MY NAME'S DAN SANTOS AND- I'M-
WITH COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA AND- ALSO DISPLACING
TECHNICIAN WITH EIGHTEEN T. FOR
TWENTY THREE YEARS GOOD TO SEE
YOU MISTER PATTERSON- I'M ALSO
FROM FRESNO. AND YOU KNOW AS YOU
KNOW IT'S THE HEART OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY VALLEY OF GREAT
WEALTH AND EXTREME POVERTY- WE
ARE ALSO THE VALLEY OF THE
DIGITAL DESERT IS WHAT I CALL
IT. AND WHAT I'VE DONE AND I'VE
- IS I'M WORKING IN SUBDIVISIONS
LAST WEEK I WORKED IN FIREBALL
BEFORE THAT I WAS WORKING IN
MENDOTA WORKING ALL OF PRESENTS
WEST SIDE. AND OTHER TECHNICIANS
WORKING IN THE SAID WE'RE STILL
. TWO BRAND NEW SUBDIVISIONS
COPPER NETWORKS THAT ARE LIKE
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD THE
TECHNOLOGY GIVES YOU A- DATA
SPEED OF ABOUT. SIXTY TEN MAGS
STILL BUILDING IT RIGHT NOW. I
JUST CAN'T BELIEVE IT- YOU KNOW.
I BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS TO
HONOR THE SOCIAL CONTRACT. OF
LIKE WHAT WAS. SPARKED THE
DEPLOYMENT OF RURAL
ELECTRIFICATION. AND THE
TELEPHONE SERVICE IT'S GOT TO BE
UNIVERSAL UNIVERSAL SERVICE.
IT'S ALSO GOT TO BE A SERVICE
WHICH HAS TO LIE ON A DURABLE
NETWORK AND THAT NETWORK- IN OUR
VIEWS AS A TECHNICIAN HAS TO BE
AN OPTICAL FIBER NETWORK. AN
OPTICAL FIBRE BACKBONE WILL
SERVE YOU FOR GENERATIONS MAY
COST MORE TO BUILD TAKE A LITTLE
LONGER BUT IN THE END. YOU'RE
DONE. WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
NATURAL DISASTERS AND- THOSE
LITTLE CRITTERS CALLED SQUIRRELS
. YES THEY WREAK HAVOC ON A
NETWORK BUT THERE'S A SOLUTION
YOU KNOW YOU HARDEN THE NETWORK
YOU HARDEN THE AERIALS YOU
UNDERGROUND WHERE YOU CAN. I'VE
SEEN UNDERGROUNDING GOING ON BUT
IT. THESE COMPANIES THEY DON'T
WANNA UNDERGROUND THEY DON'T
WANT TO HAVE THE EXPENSE. I'VE
BEEN IN PLACERVILLE WHERE THERE
UNDERGROUNDING CONDUIT IN THE
FIRE AREAS. YOU SEE THAT
TELEPHONE POLES WITH THE
TELEPHONE WIRE CRISSCROSSING THE
ROAD FIFTY FEET FROM WHERE THE
UNDERGROUNDING IS GOING ON IN
THE REFUSING TO DO IT. BUT LET
ME GET BACK TO ANOTHER PROBLEM
WHICH IS. IT'S SUCH A HUGE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD THIS
BIGGEST ONE THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
MY LIFETIME PROBABLY WE DON'T
HAVE THE TECHNICIANS TO DO IT
AND SO MANY CASES WORKERS TRYING
TO BUILD A PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE'RE TRYING
TO START TO BUILD THE CAPACITY
WITH SOME OF THE VOCATIONAL
TRAINING PROGRAMS. TO HELP
PEOPLE GET QUICKLY INTO THOSE
JOBS WHICH THERE'S A LOT OF JOBS
IF YOU GO TO THE JOB WEBSITES
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TECHNICIANS
THE TECHNICIANS OF US THAT ARE
THERE ARE OVERLOADED WE CAN'T
KEEP UP WITH THE DAY TO DAY WORK
LET ALONE VANDERBILTS AND LET
ALONE THIS HUGE INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROJECTS SO I JUST HOPE THAT YOU
WOULD TAKE THIS AND LET'S GO
WITH IT AND PARTNER WITH US TO
THE EXTENT WITH WHOEVER IS OUT
THERE DEVELOPING THE CAPACITY
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
STRENGTHEN THE VOCATIONAL
TRAINING PROGRAMS IN THOSE
PIPELINES AND THEN EVENTUALLY
BRING THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
DISPLACED WORKERS FROM OTHER.
INDUSTRIES LIKE THE PETROLEUM
INDUSTRY'S FOREVER. BRING THEM
INTO THIS PIPELINE THAT WILL
GIVE THEM THE JOBS OF THE FUTURE
I THINK IT WOULD BE THE- A GOOD
INVESTMENT BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT IT'S PART OF YOUR BUDGET.
BUT I THINK THAT YOU CAN FIND
THE MONEY AND I THINK YOU'LL
FIND IT'LL MAKE YOUR PROJECT
MORE SUCCESSFUL. BUT IT'S GOT TO
BE HIGH ROAD IT'S GOT TO BE GOOD
PAY GOOD TRAINING. OSHA
CERTIFICATIONS IN OPTICAL FIBER
ALL OF THE SKILLS TO GOING TO
BUILDING A NETWORK WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO THAT. WE'D
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES CAN WE FIND OUT HOW MANY
ARE ON THE LINE JUST BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO RUN OUT OF TIME.
BEFORE WE HAVE TO LEAVE THE
ROOM- RIGHT. TWELVE THIRTY IF
YOU WANT ME VERBALLY TELL YOU
THAT. YES IF YOU CAN YEAH SURE
I'M I'M SHOWING FIVE- FIVE
PARTIES HAVE DIALED AND GOT ONE
AND Q. RIGHT NOW FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ALL RIGHT SO IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE IF YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS LIMITED WE
WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU WE JUST
DON'T WANT WANT TO RUN HAVE
TAUGHT OUT OF THE TIME BEFORE WE
HAVE TO LEAVE THE ROOM. WELCOME
THANK YOU AND IT IS ONE ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE NUMBER SIX I AM
SORRY NINE NUMBER EIGHT. LINE
EIGHT YOUR YOUR YOUR OPEN STE
STE OKAY. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. MY NAME
IS CHARGED LEO TODAY REPRESENT
THE PRODUCTS HERE FROM. YEAH
HAVE BEEN THE FOR AND STARTING
THE FUTURE OF BROADBAND ACCESS
AND UNCLES THE DEPLOYMENT OF
UNIVERSALLY AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE
AND COMPETITIVE HIGH SPEED
NETWORKS. UNDER THE
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW THE CPUC AT
THE V. P. IS PASSED WITH
IDENTIFY AREAS THAT LACK MIDDLE
MILE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MEET
THE CONDITIONS OF OPEN ACCESS.
SUFFICIENT CAPACITY AND
AFFORDABLE RATES. HAVING MIDDLE
MILE OF THE TRUCK IS NOT ENOUGH
. IT MUST BE OPEN. HAVE TO
CAPACITY AND BE AFFORDABLE. WITH
THOSE THREE CONDITIONS THAT MIND
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT BEHIND
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW AND THE CPUC
HIS GOAL IS CLEAR. I DON'T AND
FACILITATE THE COMES. OPEN
FUTURE PROOF AND A NOW. WE NEED
LEVERAGE PUBLIC DOLLARS TO THEM
THAT WILL LAST GENERATIONS. THE
CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE RESULTED
IN YOUNG GIRLS IN SALINAS
SITTING OUTSIDE A TACO BELL THE
TO TRY AND GET A SIGNAL FOR
SCHOOL. IF WE BUILD AND BUILD
BOLDLY THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN
AGAIN. BEFORE WILL APPROVED
GROUP ACCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WILL DO MORE THAN
JUST AND DIGITAL DIVIDE IT WILL
ALSO ENDED EQUITY DIVIDE IN
BROADBAND. OFFERING OPTION TO
THE MANY WHO ALREADY HAVE ACCESS
BUT SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD IT. A
SUPER MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
CONSIDER BROADBAND AS IMPORTANT
THEIR LIVES AS ELECTRICITY AND
WATER. IF THE LEGISLATURE. OF SB
ONE FIVE SIX REFLECT THE
IMPORTANCE. BUT THEY HAVE
ALREADY DONE PALATABLE WORKS TO
PARK ON THE STRONIE. LET'S MAKE
THE MOST OF IT AND BUILD A
BETTER FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS SHANE A ENGLAND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
CONTROL I CLEAN THAT STUDENTS.
AND CRIED AND CALLING TO EXPRESS
OUR CONTINUED STRONG SUPPORT ALL
OF THE STATES INVESTMENT IN
BUILDING OF PUBLICLY OWNED OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK AND
ALSO IN THE STATE STRONG
OVERSIGHT OF THAT PROCESS. WHILE
THIS NETWORK COULD BRING US ONE
STEP CLOSER TO BRIDGING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. PRECIADO DEEP
DIVE INTO COMMON. I AM SORRY TO
THE PROJECTS MY IN A LARGER
ISSUE. AND THE QUESTION THAT
WISH ASK FOR ROUND THE START OF
OVERALL APPROACH- THAT'S NOT.
AND THE COMBINATION OF BILLS BY
AND PICK WE- THAT IS BEING
CONSIDERED. TO ENSURE THE STATE
IN I ATTACK IN THE- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC FUNDS ARE TO
THE BUILDER. DURABLE PERMANENT
AT. WITHOUT LAW TERM LIFE FOR
THAT IS ONLY JOB FOR. BENEFIT
OUT WE HAVE ANY OF THIS CAN BE
DONE BY. A AND- BECAUSE THAT WE
THE LEAGUE OF ALL I. ASSEMBLY
FUTURE ON. WHEN SIGNIFICANT MY-
AND ALSO WITH AGAIN SAME PER.
I'M NOT TO ENTER AVAILABLE FOR A
HIGH THE TERM. FOR ACCESS TO
PASS. AFFORDABLE AND RELY
INTERNET. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
LOOK TO CONTINUING TO GET CAN'T. THANK YOU. AND THEN ARMY ANY
OTHER PER COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
THE AND THEN AT THE TIME AGAIN
IT'S ZERO. AND GIVE ME A MOMENT
HERE WE DO HAVE WON WITH AN
OPERATOR GIVE US JUST ONE MOMENT. FOR MINOR IS ONE MM ZERO. WILL
NOT GO TO LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MELANIE FIGUEROA ON
BEHALF OF VERIZON THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS COMMITTEE HEARING
I'M FROM VERIZON PERSPECTIVE IN
ORDER TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE WE REALLY NEED AT ALL OF
THE ABOVE STRATEGY AND WE NEED
TO ENSURE A TECHNOLOGY INCLUDES
THAT PROCESS. THAT AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
INCLUDING A WIRELESS AND FIXED
WIRELESS OPTIONS AT THE HIGH
PERFORMANCE BROADBAND ACCESS
POINTS. UTILIZING WIRELESS
ACCESS SOLUTION COULD BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA BY NEEDING SPEEDS
REQUIRED BY THE I. I. I. I. J.
A. AND HELPING STREAMLINED
DEPLOYMENT TIMES AS WELL AS
LOWER DEPLOYMENT COSTS. AND
IMPROVE THE NETWORK EFFICIENCY
IN. FIXED WIRELESS BROADBAND
ACCESS TECHNOLOGY PROVIDE
COMPETITIVE SEATS CAPACITY AND
LATENCY IS THAT ME AND THE USER
NAME AND COULD BE TIME TO
MARKET. THE BENEFITS OF FIXED
WIRELESS ACCESS MAY BE
PARTICULARLY HELPFUL AND
UNDERSERVED AND UNSERVED RURAL
AREAS ADDED MAY ADD AS AS THAT
MAY BETTER MEDICAID THE UNIQUE.
CHALLENGES SUCH AS GEOGRAPHY
TOPOGRAPHY AND ACCESS COSTS IN
THOSE AREAS LASTLY MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT
TO DEPLOY IT LAST MILE
CONNECTIONS TO CUSTOMERS.
LOCATIONS VIA FIBER CLARKSVILLE
CABLE WIRELESS THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. AND CURRENTLY NO
FURTHER IN Q. AGAIN WE WANT TO
THANK PRES WE WANT TO THOSE IN
IN COMMENT OUR SPEAKERS AT THE
PODIUM TODAY AND OUR MEMBERS FOR
JOINING US WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE AND CONTINUE OVERSIGHT
AND WE THANK YOU FOR COMING-
TODAY ARE HEARING IT IS FINISHED.